Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans « Septante Minutes avec ». Jusqu'à présent, dans ce podcast, j'ai principalement passé 70 minutes avec des politiciens, des sociologues, des journalistes.
Et la logique, c'est juste que j'aime passer du temps avec des gens qui m'adressent moi. L'Aiguille Rouge, c'est ça.
Et du coup, c'était tout à fait évident à mes yeux que je devais inviter Dan Gagnon.
Dan Gagnon, c'est un humoriste belgo-québécois et animateur TV à la RTBF. Il fait du stand-up depuis six ans maintenant et on voit qu'il a vraiment ça dans le sang.
Je voulais discuter avec lui de son point de vue un peu atypique sur la comédie et l'art de la blague.
Mais du coup, comme c'est un humoriste, c'est forcément un épisode un peu inhabituel puisqu'on fait beaucoup de vannes et qu'on rigole ensemble tout le long de l'épisode.
Faut savoir que Dan adore faire des digressions, donc à la base, l'enregistrement a duré deux heures. J'en ai coupé certaines pour vous épargner, mais voilà, soyons clairs, après 70 minutes, le podcast part complètement hors sujet.
Moi, j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à faire cet épisode, mais voilà, si vous écoutez et que c'est pas trop votre truc, franchement, y a aucun souci.
OK ? Let's go. Hey, bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce nouvel épisode de « Septante Minutes avec ». Aujourd'hui, pour ce septième épisode, on reçoit Dan Gagnon. Dan Gagnon, salut.
Salut, comment ça va, Guillaume H. ?
Guillaume H., c'est moi. Mais ça va très bien. Très content de t'avoir avec moi pour cet épisode. Tu nous appelles depuis le Canada, donc depuis la contrée neigeuse et froide.
Oui, mais ceci étant dit, donc je sais pas quand l'épisode va être diffusé, mais j'ai vu des images de Belgique aujourd'hui, moment de l'enregistrement, où y avait de la neige aussi en Belgique.
Mais oui, moi, de mon côté, ça fait déjà trois fois qu'il neige, je pense.
S'il neige, je suis pas au courant, mais faudrait peut-être que je sorte de chez moi pour savoir, mais je-
Mais toi, t'es Bruxellois, non ?
Ouais, ouais, c'est ça, ouais.
Oui, mais ça, il faut jamais oublier que, sur le plan de la météo, dès que tu vis dans une ville, y a cette bulle de pollution qui est un peu comme la bulle dans « The Dome » de Stephen King,
qui vous protège de toute forme de météo négative.
Uh-huh. Ouais. J'étais inquiet qu'on soit short au niveau des questions que j'ai préparées, mais je pense qu'on est bien partis niveau digression, là, ça.
Est-ce que t'as plus que zéro question ?
Ouais, j'en ai, j'en ai, ouais, j'en ai plus que huit.
T'en as combien, sérieusement ?
J'sais pas, 12 ? Ouais, un truc comme ça.
Ben écoute, ce sera un épisode en 12 parties.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Non, mais je te l'ai dit et je le dis sur antenne comme ça tout le monde le sait, si vous l'entendez qui me coupe, c'est pas qu'il est malpoli, c'est moi qui lui ai dit.
J'suis désolé, moi, j'suis un chien. Si t'agites un bâton devant moi, je fais : « Yeah, jouez ! » Et je deviens trop intense.
Donc faut pas hésiter à me couper.
On va peut-être commencer par un peu retracer ton parcours et dire qui tu es en fait, parce que je sais pas si les gens savent, mais qui est ce mec en fait ?
Pourquoi y a quelqu'un qui parle pendant l'introduction ? Dites-lui qu'il ferme sa gueule.
Ben, Dan Gagnon, tu es le représentant de la farce canadienne en Belgique. Tu es arrivé ici en 2004. Quand je dis ici, je dis la Belgique.
Oui.
Tu t'es fait importer, t'as passé la douane via Myriam Leroy, qui t'a ramené ici en Belgique.
Totalement.
Et puis, tu as bossé, je ne sais pas trop comment t'as fait, mais t'es arrivé et déjà un an après, tu faisais direct le 6/9 sur NRJ, la station de radio.
Comment t'as fait ça, d'ailleurs ?
Ben, c'était un peu, en gros, j'ai fait des études en communication. Autrement dit, je voulais être un chômeur avec un diplôme.
C'est vraiment ça la carrière qui s'amène à toi. Donc, j'ai rencontré Myriam qui était en Erasmus à sa dernière année et je l'ai suivie en Belgique.
Donc, elle a fini, donc son Erasmus se terminait en mai. Et moi, je suis arrivé en septembre de la même année. Et j'ai commencé en faisant un stage à la DH.
Et c'est comme ça, donc j'étais deux mois en Belgique, j'avais pas de papiers, c'était un stage non rémunéré. Je suis rentré chez moi et puis je suis revenu début février.
Et là, l'objectif, c'était vraiment de se trouver un boulot dans mon domaine.
Mmm-hmm.
Et comme n'importe qui qui sort d'une école de communication, c'était assez galère. Je me souviens, j'ai eu un entretien avec TV Com, donc la télévision locale du Brabant wallon.
OK.
Et à un moment donné, tu finis par devoir y aller au bluff, là. Et je me souviens, je suis arrivé carrément dans des bureaux en disant : « Ouais, je viens déposer mon CV.
Est-ce que le directeur est ici ? » Ils m'ont dit : « Il vient juste cet après-midi ». Je fais : « Pas de problème, je vais revenir ».
Et donc j'ai essayé de faire un stage là-bas, ça a pas fonctionné, mais à force, à force, à force, je suis arrivé dans la libre antenne de-- c'était Mickaël qui fait « Sans interdit ».
Je crois qu'il est encore en France. C'était Mickaël, Tof et Jack à l'époque pour les plus vieux. Et il m'avait invité.
J'avais passé une soirée avec eux dans la libre antenne.
Et de fil en aiguille, j'ai fait des petits jobs. Et quand je suis revenu, Walid, qui fait aujourd'hui en Belgique le « C'est presque sérieux » sur la Première, je venais de signer parce que Mickaël avait signé pour partir en France.
Donc lui avait signé et il cherchait un gars pour faire, un gars ou une fille, pour l'aider à écrire des blagues et pour faire la réalisation, puis être troisième animateur, mais vraiment celui qui est là
comme du sel dans un plat, tu vois, avec parcimonie.
Et moi, j'ai dit : « Pas de problème, je sais faire de la réalisation », ce qui était absolument pas vrai. « Et je vais être discret sur antenne », ce qui a pas été vrai non plus.
Ce qui fait que le lendemain de la première, j'ai été convoqué dans le bureau du directeur d'antenne.
Nice.
Où on m'a dit : « Quand on dit parler un peu, ça veut dire genre une fois toutes les 10 minutes, pas 10 minutes à toutes les phrases ».
Et aussi, pendant deux mois, j'ai quelqu'un qui devait m'aider à faire la réalisation parce que j'étais pas assez doué et je merdais.
Et cette personne-là, c'est aussi quelqu'un qui est super connu médiatiquement aujourd'hui, c'est Cyril Deteille qui anime « C'est vous qui le dites » sur Vivacité.
Ah ouais, d'accord, ouais.
Et qui est quelqu'un avec qui je me suis super bien entendu, qui est resté avec moi pendant deux mois pour m'accompagner dans tous mes mensonges professionnels.
Donc la raison pour laquelle j'ai réussi rapidement, c'est que j'ai menti.
Mais oui, meilleure technique. Et ouais, après ça, t'es arrivé à la RTBF, où t'as commencé en 2007 comme chroniqueur.
Et puis après, en 2009, t'étais chroniqueur pour « Sans chichi », une émission, je sais pas trop comment on peut décrire, mais c'est un peu public féminin pour la ménagère, c'est ça ?
C'était en fin d'après-midi. C'était un peu ce que moi j'appelle l'horaire d'Oprah Winfrey, là.
Moi, je trouve que cette émission était brillante d'accompagnement, c'est-à-dire que c'était plein de gens.
Et la première saison, les deux premières saisons même, c'était dans un loft et c'était plein de chroniqueurs dans un loft, donc certains autour d'une table, en cuisine, tout ça.
Et y avait ce côté-là où, que t'aimes ou que t'aimes pas l'émission, c'était agréable à mettre en fond sonore parce que c'était un vrai mood d'accompagnement.
Moi, j'adore Joyce Coriz, que j'ai rencontrée là. Et c'est totalement un coup de bol, encore une fois. Je suis arrivé à la RTBF parce que la RTBF, à un moment donné, fait un grand casting
général pour voir est-ce qu'y a des talents en Belgique qu'on connaît pas.
Puis c'était le directeur artistique, Vincent Auziau, qui est encore là d'ailleurs, qui rencontrait tout le monde.
Et quand on s'est parlé, il m'a dit : « Tu sais quoi ? Je vais te faire un test sur antenne, voir ce que tu donnes.
» Et j'arrive pour faire un test. Et y avait une émission qui s'appelait « Ma télé bien-aimée », qui en Belgique est un genre de Arthur.
C'était l'équivalent des « Enfants de la télé » d'Arthur, si tu veux. C'était avec Jean-Louis Leye. Et je fais le test et la productrice qui était Marie-France B-- bon, je fais que du name dropping de gens,
de noms que les gens connaissent pas.
Donc la productrice, c'était Chris Rock. Et je vais un peu upgrader mon name dropping. Et elle dit : « Il est cool le petit Québécois.
» Et on enregistrait à l'époque genre trois jours de suite, trois émissions. Et je me dis : « Cool, ma carrière en télé démarre.
Je passe de la radio à la télé, je vais devenir une star. » Et dans la deuxième salle d'enregistrement, le lendemain matin, donc à la fin de ma sixième émission, je reçois un mail qui me dit : « L'émission est annulée.
Merci pour votre travail. Bisous. » Et je fais : « Bon, ben... »
C'est dark.
C'est vraiment, ouais, c'est ça. Et un an après, la RTBF m'a rappelé pour participer au casting donc du programme qui allait devenir « Sans chichi ».
Et c'est là que j'ai rencontré Joëlle Scorel. En fait j'ai fait un an avec elle, puis j'ai dit : « Je cesse » parce qu'y avait une nouvelle télé qui démarrait, qui était,
qui était, voilà, une télé faite entre les gens de chez Cine Télé Revue, puis bon, Boris Portnoy, mais disons Barack Obama.
Et eux créaient une télé pour les stars et j'avais une séquence comique sur cette télé. Et euh-
Ouais, ça, c'était Star TV, c'est ça ?
Star TV, exactement. Et au bout d'un an, la RTBF m'a recontacté pour me proposer une nouvelle séquence et j'ai accepté. J'étais tellement pas, oh j'étais pas bon.
C'était un studio fait en tôle là-bas ou quoi ?
Non, mais les studios étaient OK, l'idée était OK. Les gens étaient-- moi, j'étais pas bon. J'avais genre deux minutes par, ça s'appelait « La minute de Dan ».
J'avais une minute par jour, mais ils m'ont dit : « Tu peux faire un peu n'importe quoi », mais j'avais proposé plein de choses, dont des, c'était une horreur.
Si vous retombez là-dessus, franchement, c'est dégueulassement mauvais. C'est-
Je vais chercher après.
Ah oui, mais cherche, puis publie si tu veux. Je mérite d'être humilié publiquement. C'était des-- parce que les choses dont j'suis fier, des fois, rien à voir.
Je prenais des séquences de séries télé connues, puis je refaisais le doublage moi-même. Mais-
Ouais, classique, ouais.
J'ai pas 15 accents. Moi, j'suis capable d'en faire à peu près un, puis peut-être un deuxième où je fais genre : « Mais alors, je vais te tuer.
» Et c'était pathétique. Le pire, je crois, c'est vraiment le moment où j'ai commencé à prendre des vidéos d'animaux, puis je doublais les animaux.
Et j'avais pris une vidéo de pingouins qui était intense et j'ai juste crié comme s'il était sur la coke pendant une minute.
C'était pathétique. C'est juste moi qui faisais comme ça : « Ah ! » Et c'était la meilleure des séquences que j'ai faites sur Star TV.
Donc merci beaucoup parce qu'ils m'ont quand même payé. Et honnêtement, légalement, je crois qu'ils avaient le droit de me demander de l'argent.
Ouais, je comprends pas pourquoi t'as honte. Je vois pas, je vois pas du tout.
En fait, j'ai pas vraiment honte. Je sais juste que socialement, c'est bien de dire que j'ai honte, mais en fait, je me suis bien amusé.
Je regrette absolument rien. Et puis c'est pas la pire chose que j'ai faite.
Yes. OK. Et donc après quelques années de « Sans chichi », t'es passé de la télé et t'as commencé à faire bah du one man show, de la comédie.
Ouais.
T'es parti en tournée en 2012.
Exactement.
C'était une évidence pour toi ?
C'est, les rock stars au Québec, c'est des humoristes, règle de général. Et euh-
C'est quoi ? Genre Garou et Bryan Adams ?
Bien joué. Bryan Adams est canadien, mais il parle français, donc excellent. Il est canadien, donc très bien joué. Non, mes idoles à moi, je veux dire, y a une école nationale de l'humour au Québec.
Les humoristes sont absolument partout. Ils font des scores incroyables. Je veux dire, on est 7 millions, on a un peu moins de 7 millions de francophones, peut-être 6 millions et demi de francophones.
Et t'as plusieurs humoristes qui font 200 000 billets vendus par tournée. C'est énorme le pourcentage. Y a genre 40 one man shows qui partent par année.
C'est des vraies stars. Moi, j'ai toujours voulu faire ça, mais je me sentais excessivement intimidé par la scène, par tout ça.
J'ai toujours été complètement introverti, introverti, limite maladif. Et de me dire que j'allais m'exposer comme ça, j'osais pas, mais j'ai commencé à écrire des sketchs.
J'avais peut-être quoi, 12, 13 ans. C'était certainement excellent. Si je les retrouve, je suis sûr que c'est du génie. Et j'avais osé monter.
Et quand je travaillais chez NRJ, y a Gilles Morin, qui était le producteur de Kings of Comedy, qui arrivait avec une logique vraiment beaucoup de stand-up très très très proche de ce que le stand-up est en Amérique du Nord.
À preuve, Kings of Comedy a appartenu pendant un bout de temps à 50 % à Juste pour rire, donc une entreprise phare du Québec.
Et il m'a dit : « Bah viens voir ça, je pense que ça va te plaire. » Donc je suis allé voir. J'ai interviewé certains des humoristes aussi, sur antenne, sur NRJ.
Puis au bout d'un an, il m'a dit : « Je crée un festival. » Donc c'était le Brussels Comedy Festival à l'époque.
Mmm-hmm.
Et qui est devenu le Karmezo à un moment donné, qui est devenu Juste pour rire Bruxelles puis le Karmezo. Et il m'a dit : « Je fais un genre de festival off à côté et je fais des soirées où c'est deux humoristes font chacun 45 minutes.
J'aimerais te proposer de le faire si ça t'intéresse. » Je fais : « Bah, l'occasion est belle. » Il dit : « Je vais t'aider, je vais t'accompagner là-dedans.
» Et à vie, je devrais donner tout le mérite à Gilles de m'avoir permis de faire quelque chose que je pensais jamais que je ferais.
Je pensais jamais que j'aurais le courage d'oser puis de faire un premier pas sur la scène. Et j'ai tellement chié dans mon froc.
La première fois, c'était au Théâtre O, donc à Watermael-Boitsfort, un tout petit peu en banlieue de Bruxelles.
Mmm-hmm.
Et j'étais arrivé genre trois, quatre heures à l'avance. C'est une scène ouverte qui s'appelle le Made in Brussels Show, qui existe encore aujourd'hui.
C'était la première vraie scène ouverte de Bruxelles faite par Sarah Vane-, je veux dire, par Hillary Clinton. Et-
Et le premier sketch que j'ai présenté, c'est à ce jour, et c'est vraiment triste quand on y pense, le sketch qui a eu le plus de succès dans ma carrière.
C'était quoi ? C'était le-
C'est le sketch sur la neige. C'était le sketch-
Ah oui, oui
C'est le premier. Et donc, j'étais en première partie de-- non, c'était pas le « Made in Brussels » show la première fois, c'était la première partie de Cody.
Cody était là et j'arrive et je fais genre, je dois faire genre huit minutes. Les six premières minutes, c'est un bide monumental, un silence, mais j'ai des semi-rires.
Donc moi, je suis déjà content. Puis je finis avec le sketch sur la neige que je faisais deux minutes à l'époque et qui marche vraiment bien.
Et moi, je remonte en haut, genre les loges, c'est les toilettes pour hommes, tu vois, en gros.
OK, ouais.
Ils transforment ça en loge. Et je monte, mais fier comme un paon, tu vois, en disant : « J'ai dominé. Le stand-up, c'est moi.
So, genre, penche-toi, puis baise mes couilles. » Je sais pas exact, mais vrai, j'ai un excès de confiance et de vulgarité.
Et Gilles, je me souviens, me prend dans les bras puis il me dit : « T'inquiète, le pire est passé. » Mais moi, j'avais pas réalisé jusque-là que ça avait été mauvais, tu vois.
Je fais : « Ah ouais ? Bah, c'est pas grave, je suis content quand même. » Puis après ça, je me suis bien amusé. Quelques mois après, je faisais le 45 minutes.
Et c'est marrant parce que je suis devenu suffisamment vieux pour que dans mon passé, y ait plein de gens dans mes anecdotes qui soient devenus des stars.
La personne avec qui je faisais le 45 minutes à l'époque, c'était Pablo Andrés.
D'accord, ouais.
Oui, qui complètement, en Belgique, je veux dire, c'est une star. Il a fait des tournées de fou, il a joué, il a rempli.
C'était quoi ? C'est le Palais 12 dans lequel il a joué ou la Forêt Nationale ? C'est ridicule. Il doit approcher.
Je veux dire, il a fait dernièrement, quand c'était la Coupe du Monde, il était avec tous les joueurs des Diables Rouges pour faire des séquences qui faisaient des millions de views. Le gars, c'est un-
Ouais, ouais pour le coup, donc il est très populaire, très connu, mais c'est un style d'humour très différent du tien pour le coup.
Vous faites pas vraiment le même genre de vanne.
Oh, rien à voir. Il fait des personnages. Mais j'ai hâte de voir son nouveau show, justement. C'est « Démasqué », je crois qu'il s'appelle.
Et c'est justement, il fait un mélange entre ses personnages et lui qui a envie de parler au public. Et j'ai super hâte de voir ce qu'il va faire.
Mais quand tu... Je veux dire, moi, je compte plus le nombre de personnes que j'ai croisées qui m'ont galactiquement explosé au niveau de la popularité.
Quand j'étais chez NRJ, on parlait de NRJ, un des stagiaires que j'ai eus, c'est un certain Paul, ou vous le connaissez un petit peu plus sous le nom de Stromae.
Ah ah.
Il était stagiaire dans une de mes émissions. Je lui ai demandé, j'ai : « Écoute, Paul, ça te va si aujourd'hui, tu fais un petit montage avec les messages qu'on nous a laissés sur le répondeur ?
Tu crois que ça va aller ? » Il m'a dit oui. Puis deux ans après, je m'endormais au Canada en le voyant faire « Alors on danse » devant 12 000 personnes.
Je fais : « Ah bah ouais ».
Ouais, ouais.
Guillaume a été stagiaire chez Kings of Comedy, un autre-
Ouais, pas moi, on parle de Guihome, le youtubeur.
Guihome.
Exactement. De Guillaume Vaudetin, qui est aussi totalement hilarant, mais c'est,
je repense toujours à la phrase que Seb Lía,
un humoriste français, m'avait dite, c'est : « Quand tu commences en stand-up, tu mens sur le nombre d'années d'expérience que t'as en l'augmentant », en disant : « Ça fait sept, huit ans que je fais ça.
» Puis quand ça fait vraiment sept, huit ans, tu commences à trouver ça gênant quand on te dit : « Ça fait combien de temps que tu le fais ?
» et que t'es toujours pas connu. Donc, tu commences à mentir à l'inverse : « Oh moi, ça fait trois, quatre ans, là. » Moi, j'en suis au stade où je dis que je viens de commencer depuis six mois.
Ça va. Mais oui, mais tu vois des stars monter autour de toi. Tu fais ta tournée qui se passe plutôt bien.
Et je pense que t'avais même, 'fin bon, parce que tu t'écrases sous la modestie, mais t'avais quand même rempli, si je me souviens bien, le Cirque Royal assez rapidement.
Oui, en cinq ans. On avait fait un petit défi. Verino l'a repris en France. Et juste pour préciser, parce qu'on m'en parle souvent, Verino a fait la même chose que j'avais fait, lui à l'Olympia.
Mais Verino, c'est quelqu'un avec qui je m'entends méga bien et qui m'avait appelé en disant : « Est-ce que ça te dérange ?
» Puis je fais : « Absolument pas. » Et j'avais recommandé des équipes vidéo pour aller faire son défi. Le point, c'était remplir le Cirque Royal, 2 000 places en 50 jours à 10 € la place.
Et moi-même, j'ai rien inventé. Et j'ai été toujours très clair. Quand on m'a demandé où t'as trouvé l'idée-
C'est simple comme idée.
C'est ça. Où t'as trouvé l'idée ? C'était un Québécois qui avait fait ça à Chicago parce qu'il voulait passer chez Oprah et remplir la plus grande salle.
Donc j'ai... Puis même t'as, c'était Fazi Faz à l'époque qui avait fait ça au Cirque Royal carrément. Et donc voilà, j'ai rien inventé.
C'est juste un concept pour essayer de,
de te faire connaître. Et ma modestie vient pas de là, parce que là, au contraire, j'avais rempli en moins de 50 jours, j'avais été invité au JT alors que mes parents étaient en Belgique pour venir voir le show.
C'était fantastique d'ego. Genre celui qui allait devenir Premier ministre avait appelé, son cabinet avait appelé pour obtenir les dernières places disponibles.
Mais c'était qui à l'époque ?
Mais c'était pas le Premier ministre encore, c'était Elio Di Rupo qui finalement est devenu-
Ah ouais, ouais.
Parce qu'il
y avait, le cabinet avait appelé pour avoir les dernières places. Donc c'était fantastique.
Ils avaient dû ouvrir les portes plus rapidement au Cirque Royal parce qu'il y avait tellement de files que ça débordait dans la rue et que ça devenait compliqué pour la sécurité.
T'avais des revendeurs de tickets qui devaient rien comprendre en disant : « Mais c'est qui cette paye ? » C'est, en fait, c'est la définition même du buzz.
C'est quelqu'un qui fait quelque chose de surprenant. Et là, s'ils ont dit : « Ah, il est pas connu », puis il remplit la plus grande salle, la deuxième plus grande salle à Bruxelles.
C'est juste ça. Je veux dire, avant d'être un humoriste, je suis un businessman. Et pour moi, les deux sont pas incompatibles, mais c'est vraiment ça.
Je suis d'un instinct de businessman. Je viens d'une famille où on m'a appris ça, puis j'ai toujours adoré ça. Puis j'adore le calcul du risque, parce que pour moi, c'est un faux risque.
Mais mon humilité vient pas de ce moment-là. Au contraire, mon ego vient de ce moment-là. Mon humilité vient du fait qu'après,
on a fait une tournée qui s'appelait le « Mégalomaniaque Tour » où c'était les plus grandes salles de Wallonie et on s'est tapé des
bides monumentaux au point où au Palais des Beaux-Arts de Charleroi,
y avait tellement peu de personnes qu'ils m'ont pas fait jouer dans la salle.
On a joué dans une salle de réunion en haut parce qu'y avait pas assez de gens. C'est pas la gêne, ça ?
Ouais, ouais, mais t'es aussi le premier à expliquer que c'est le genre de baffes, le genre d'échec qui construit.
Donc, j'imagine que tu en es sorti plus gros.
Ben oui, mais les échecs... Et on a, je sais que, je veux dire, on se connaît un peu hors antenne, hein, Guillaume. On en a déjà parlé.
N'est-ce pas ?
Y a plein de choses dans la vie qui sont des mauvais réflexes, des mauvais instincts. Et voilà, craindre l'échec, si tu veux réussir quoi que ce soit, en gros, c'est pas compliqué.
Avant d'être bon, il faut que t'apprennes. Puis une des meilleures façons d'apprendre, c'est de te planter. Pour être bon, plante-toi.
L'échec et le génie viennent du même point. C'est le fait de prendre des risques. Plante-toi, c'est le cheat code, c'est le Konami Code de l'expérience, des échecs.
Super référence. Mais ouais, mais, j'vais,
on va revenir là-dessus dans deux secondes, mais en fait, pour continuer, juste après ta première tournée, t'as commencé un late show sur la RTBF, le Dan Late Show,
et je fast forward très très vite, mais quand tu l'as clôturé, quand tu l'as conclu, ce late show sur la deux,
tu as conclu avec ce discours-là, en expliquant, en t'adressant aux Belges directement, en leur disant que eux, spécifiquement,
avaient très très peur du risque et qu'il y avait, tu appelais ça une culture de l'immobilisme, je m'en souviens.
Oui. Ça peut être vexant.
Non, non, mais moi, j'aime bien. Mais perso, quand j'ai entendu ça, ça m'a un peu fait ouvrir les yeux.
Est-ce que toi, tu estimes que c'est un truc qui est spécifique aux Belges, genre plus que les Français, plus que les autres Européens ?
Tu penses que y a un truc avec la Belgique ?
Si je veux être crédible, il faut toujours que t'aies plus de connaissances que d'opinions. Donc si je veux être crédible, j'vais comparer le Québec avec la Belgique.
Le reste, je le connais pas suffisamment. Mais pour moi, en Belgique, si tu veux sortir de l'immobilisme, ça suffit pas d'enthousiasmer les gens.
Parce que y a une espèce de... que moi, encore, c'est un surf de généralisation, hein, mais que la façon dont moi, je l'ai vécu, c'est si tu dis à quelqu'un : « Eh, j'te propose quelque chose.
Y a 99 % de chances que ça réussisse, mais si on fait rien, y a 100 % de chances que tu te fasses pas engueuler par ton boss », ben t'es coincé dans l'immobilisme.
Tu dois, je trouve, en Belgique, manier à la fois la carotte et le bâton. Il faut intégrer, et je trouve que c'est peut-être la... quand je dis que j'aime la Belgique, c'est pas du fake, parce que je dis : tous les Belges sont obligés d'être Belges.
J'veux dire, leurs parents ont baisé à l'intérieur des limites du pays, ils sont nés Belges, voilà. Moi, j'suis né ailleurs.
Donc quand je dis que j'aime la Belgique, j'ai le choix, j'ai d'autres options. C'est pas comme si le Canada, c'était un pays de merde.
C'est vraiment, c'est sincère. Et je-
Oui, c'est ça. Donc tu fais pas du bashing, quoi.
C'est ni du bashing ni de la lèche. Je m'en fous, moi, de dire : « Ah, nos amis les Belges ». Déjà, on n'est pas des amis.
Moi, j'vous aime. On verra si vous, vous m'aimez.
Y a tout un documentaire qui s'appelle, je crois, « Nos amis les Belges ». Et d'ailleurs, y a Myriam Leroy qui est dedans.
Et ils parlent, en fait, de la relation-
Ah oui ? Ah, je connaissais pas, ça m'intéresse
...entre les Français et les Belges. C'est super intéressant. J't'enverrai le lien. Mais ouais, vas-y, continue.
Et donc quand je fais une critique... Déjà, moi, j'ai pris la nationalité belge. J'ai choisi, puis ça a été un parcours du combattant pour l'obtenir, mais je considérais que je la méritais, puis
que ma connaissance de la Belgique venait d'un point d'amour.
Donc mes critiques viennent du même point d'amour. J'aime la Belgique et je trouve que se priver de la critiquer est une mauvaise façon d'aimer.
Et puis mes critiques sont peut-être pas justifiées, mais je considère que cette culture de l'immobilisme empêche tout progrès.
De la même manière, et ça, moi, je mets les deux points ensemble. Le Belge a tendance à se voir petit et ça ne fait aucun sens.
Mmh mmh. Ouais, c'est vrai. Y a beaucoup d'humilité, ouais.
Mais à ce stade-là, c'est pas de l'humilité, puis c'est même pas du complexe. C'est limite une excuse pour être mauvais.
Mais ça, y a un changement de cette culture-là. Quand je suis arrivé, on disait : « On va faire ce truc-là, mais à la belge ».
À la belge, c'était quasi toujours une façon polie de dire en moins bien.
« On va faire un Netflix à la belge, on va faire une série à la belge, on fait... » à la belge, ça voulait juste dire en moins bien, mais avec un accent, comme ça les Wallons nous écoutent, puis on peut sauver notre pognon.
C'est un peu ça, ouais.
Et il faut arrêter de se voir petit. Tu fais partie des pays, allez, t'es au minimum dans le G20, t'sais.
Mmh mmh.
T'es pas plus petit que la Suède, t'es pas plus petit que les Pays-Bas, t'es pas petit, donc ne pense pas petit. Plante-toi, fonce, crois en ce que tu fais.
Croire en ce que tu fais, ça veut pas dire : « Je pense que ça va pas se planter. » Ça veut dire : « Je crois que le,
le risque de se planter vaut la peine parce que si on réussit, ça va être bien, puis si on échoue, on va apprendre, puis la prochaine fois, ça va être bien. »
Ouais.
Et ça, la plus grande différence, on la voit aujourd'hui avec les séries télé. À l'époque, si tu disais que tu faisais une série à la belge, tu peux être certain qu'y avait « frietkot » qui était prononcé là-dedans au moins six fois,
qu'y avait des accents-
De gros accents bruxellois. Ouais. C'est ça.
Et c'était une horreur. Aujourd'hui, quand on dit faire une série à la belge, t'as un bon système avec plein de techniques, de logique, de... regarde, New York, c'est devenu exotique.
Bruxelles peut l'être. Je veux dire, quand tu vois la Statue de la Liberté, c'est pas plus cool la Statue de la Liberté que l'Atomium.
C'est juste qu'on te l'a tellement représentée qu'aujourd'hui, tu vas voir la Statue de la Liberté, puis tu payes fucking 50 balles pour monter dans une statue de fer qui est produite par la France, d'ailleurs.
C'est la même chose avec l'Atomium. Il faut que des amoureux de la Belgique nous montrent la Belgique comme ils le voient.
Et là, ça devient cool et ça devient-
Il faut qu'on soit un peu plus fiers, un peu plus, voilà, qu'on arrive à la vendre à l'étranger, entre guillemets.
Y a aucune raison d'être complexé. Encore une fois, putain, t'as trois langues dans un tout petit pays qui est au centre de l'Europe, qui est une plaque tournante, qui est important dans l'histoire du monde, qui,
au niveau des arts, j'veux dire les arts graphiques, la Belgique, c'est un incontournable, la BD, la musique, les idées même, les auteurs, tout ce que tu--
y a aucune raison de rougir l'importance historique et puis la qualité même des gens qu'y a là.
T'es pas petit. T'es pas en vélo dans une course de F1, donc arrête d'agir comme tel.
Je me demande s'il y a pas une différence aussi entre le nord et le sud du pays à ce niveau-là, parce que, tu sais, pendant longtemps, on avait toutes les blagues qu'on entendait en France
au sujet des Belges où le Belge était systématiquement,
mais idiot, con.
Ouais, le camp de service, ouais.
Ouais, c'est ça. Et donc, je me demande si à force d'entendre toutes ces choses-là, d'avoir ça inscrit vraiment en sous-texte dans la culture,
avoir tout ça, voilà, inscrit dans le marbre, je me demande si ça a pas aussi joué un petit peu culturellement, qu'on finisse par se dire : « Bah voilà, on est moins, on est en dessous, le Français sont au-dessus. »
Moi, j'appelle ça le syndrome du petit frère.
Ouais ?
Le syndrome du petit frère, c'est que vu que t'as trois ans de moins, t'es moins fort, t'es moins grand, t'es moins gros, t'as moins de connaissances, tu plais moins aux filles ou aux hommes, peu importe.
Mais à un moment donné, le syndrome du petit frère, quand les deux arrivent à l'âge adulte, ça change plus rien. T'sais que t'es... quand t'as 17 ou 14 ans, ça fait une différence, mais quand on a 31 ou 28, ça fait plus de différence.
Et j'ai l'impression, moi, j'ai dit dans les 15 ans que j'ai passé en Belgique, que la relation belgo-française ou franco-belge-
Ouais
...est passée de l'adolescence à l'âge adulte.
Ouais, ouais, y a une évolution.
Y a plus aucune raison d'avoir un complexe. Encore une fois, parce qu'à un moment donné, c'était nos amis les Belges, de manière semi-condescendante, puis nos amis les Belges, de manière au contraire un peu admirative, puis-
Ouais, et puis après, c'est devenu : « J'adore les Belges », un petit peu comme on dirait : « J'adore les chats » ou « J'adore les chiens », quoi.
Et y a eu un peu de ça aussi à un moment.
Moi, j'ai toujours... Et je me plaisais surtout à le dire en France, ça me faisait rire. Je disais : « Quand vous dites nos amis les Belges, oubliez pas que l'amitié, c'est comme le sexe, il faut un consentement.
» Tu peux pas être ami unilatéral. Tu peux dire : « Je t'aime ». Tu peux pas dire : « On est amis ». Et donc « Nos amis les Belges », j'fais : « Fuck you, j'suis pas ton ami, tu vois.
» Et avec le Québec, c'est encore plus fort. J'ai dit : « Vous nous avez colonisés. Tu peux pas dire que nous, vous nous aimez après nous avoir forcés à être vous, tu vois.
» J'ai dit : « Attendez le retour avant de... » Et puis, encore une fois, prends juste les 100 dernières années, la France et la Belgique, tu choisis quel pays, toi ?
Bah-
Les réalisations des 100 dernières années.
Euh, j'suis pas super en histoire, hein, franchement. Donc là, tu me poses un peu une colle. Attends, les 100 dernières années, mais-
C'était pas vraiment une question, c'était plutôt-
Y a eu l'occupation, y a eu le colonialisme belge, y a eu-
Oui, ça, c'est un-
Y a eu Stromae.
Oui, c'est ça. Ah, y a eu Léopold II, mais y a eu Stromae quelque part, avec « Tous les mêmes », « Ça c'est clair », genre, on dit.
Non, mais ça, c'est un truc qui est fascinant. La façon dont, dans vos écoles, personne vous enseigne Léopold II comme on l'enseigne ailleurs.
C'est vrai, mais on l'enseigne ailleurs, d'ailleurs ? Si c'est le cas, j'suis pas au courant.
Et c'est pas une blague. Tape « plus grand meurtrier de l'histoire » sur Google.
Oh.
C'est... j'dis pas ça pour faire chier, vraiment, c'est une vraie ph... genre, il est bien, il est bien placé.
C'est... Si, disons, les génocides étaient une discipline olympique, Léopold II est un espoir de médaille.
C'est une raison de trop souvent, ça, que tu me dis.
Non. Non. Non.
Regarde, j'aime bien faire des black dark, mais là, je me dissocie de ça totalement.
Et on m'a dit un... je sais pas si c'est vrai, ça, j'ai pas vérifié et je fais vraiment genre animateur de radio de droite, mais on m'a raconté quelque chose.
Ah, Alex Jones, bienvenue dans cette émission.
Ou ici, bon, Alex Jones. Ça, c'est vraiment... « They make the frogs gay. »
C'est ça.
Ça, c'est vraiment une blague de niche.
J'suis tombé sur...
Y a quelqu'un qui m'a balancé un lien et y a vraiment une étude genre de MIT ou quoi, qui montre que y a effectivement des manipulations hormonales pour changer le sexe d'une grenouille, mais pas l'orientation sexuelle.
Donc c'est complètement con parce que ta première réaction, c'est : « Waouh, c'était pas complètement con ce qu'il disait ».
Puis après, tu réalises que : « Ah, mais en fait, ils confondent le sexe et orientation sexuelle. » Donc-
En fait, tu pars de : « C'est moins con que ce que je pensais » à « C'est plus con que ce que je pensais ».
C'est ça.
Et si vous voulez comprendre tous ces Alex Jones et ces gens-là, le documentaire sur, sur Netflix sur Roger Stone, si vous ne l'avez—
Ah ouais, OK.
...jamais vu.
Je note.
Je crois qu'il s'appelle Get Me Roger Stone, en gros.
Et le documentaire sur les relations franco-belges, ça s'appelle J'adore les Belges. Voilà, je me dis comme ça parce que je me suis trompé tout à l'heure.
Donc J'adore les Belges. Et puis donc, je crois que c'est Get Me Roger Stone, où tu vois que le slogan « Make America Great Again » existait dans les années 80, un truc comme ça.
Et comment ces idées ont façonné la politique aujourd'hui, de Donald Trump. Absolument—
Attends, attends, attends. On est partis sur Alex Jones parce que, attends, il faut un peu remonter le rabbit hole.
On est partis sur Alex Jones parce que tu disais que—
Léopold II.
Tu disais que t'allais dire un truc en sonnant comme un animateur de radio de droite.
Oui, on m'a raconté que si,
l'héritage de Léopold II est pas raconté comme il devrait l'être en Belgique, c'est
parce que plusieurs familles influentes et puissantes de Belgique se sont enrichies grâce aux œuvres de Léopold II.
Conspiration. Il n'y a qu'un pas.
Eh bien, retrouvons ça dans le prochain épisode de Septante Minutes Avec, où on passera septante minutes avec—
Léopold II.
...Monseigneur Léonard. Ouais, c'est ça. OK, OK, mais oui, donc c'était—
Je sais que ça, c'était— je peux m'interrompre moi-même une seconde ?
Vas-y, interromps-toi toi-même.
C'était une de mes—
Le late show s'est arrêté et une des choses que j'aurais aimé faire avec, et je sais que ça aurait jamais fonctionné, donc c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles je l'ai pas fait, j'aurais aimé faire un,
un late show historique où ce soit exactement les mêmes codes, mais les invités ne soient que des personnages historiques qui soient interviewés au premier degré.
Ah oui, oui, OK, avec les personnages et tout.
Exactement.
Pour ça que tu disais une espèce de Last Week Tonight, mais en mode l'histoire de la Belgique. Mais OK, ouais, donc.
Non, non, non. Last Week Tonight, ça, évi— je veux dire, personne va être surpris en disant que John Oliver est un de mes BFF.
Et est-ce que tu veux entendre quelque chose, mon bon Guillaume H. ?
Vas-y, dis-moi, Dan J.
De toi à moi, évidemment, nous restons entre nous. Sache qu'en ce moment même, il existe sur les tablettes de la RTBF un pilote produit par un certain Dan J.
pour faire un genre de Last Week Tonight à la RTBF.
C'est incroyable, mais j'ai le droit de publier ça ? C'est pas top secret ?
Bah, j'imagine que c'est secret, mais eh. Au pire, ce sera pas la première fois que des gens sont fâchés contre moi.
C'est ça. Mais donc, en fait, t'es en train de nous dire que la RTBF est en train de produire une copie de Rendez-vous avec Kevin Razy sur Canal+.
Oh, c'est... Oh, ce gag était tout drôle. En fait, j'suis rendu à cet âge où quand quelque chose est vraiment drôle, j'en tousse de plaisir.
Mais, si vous voulez être très gêné pendant 10 minutes, vous pouvez regarder Rendez-vous avec Kevin Razy sur Canal+.
C'est un plagiat de— c'est une copie de Last Week Tonight, mais version française.
Ouais, mais je vais pas dire plagiat parce que pour le coup, pour moi, c'est un style d'émission. Parce qu'on peut dire, on peut—
Oui, oui, pour le coup, je—
On peut dire que mon émission était totalement un plagiat de Craig Ferguson ou de qui tu voudras.
Complètement.
Et pour moi, c'est l'équivalent. C'est devenu un genre. Ces émissions en Belgique, y a Abdel qui le fait sur Tarmac, si ma mémoire est bonne aussi. C'est un style—
Ouais, ouais, j'essayais juste d'être méprisant, mais je me suis un peu trompé dans mon mépris.
Non, mais je, on dirait vraiment que je défends ma propre maison parce que je sais que je fais souvent des choses comme ça, mais c'est— en gros, j'ai envie de reproduire les choses que j'aime.
Je pense que comme tout le monde. Mais le point, et je me souviendrai toujours de la leçon de Johnny Carson, il disait : « Peu importe ce que tu fais avec un late show » et les daily shows, donc les Stewart et—
Ouais, ouais.
...c'est la même chose. « It's all about the guy behind the desk. » Ce show, tu vas toujours regarder Jon Stewart plus que le Daily Show.
Aujourd'hui, tu regardes Trevor Noah.
Forcément, avec Kevin Razy, ça pouvait pas marcher.
Mais Kevin Ra— j'aimerais vraiment faire un podcast avec Kevin Razy parce que le mec, il est de tous les bons coups partout.
Y a eu son personnage dans une promo pour BoJack Horseman y a quelques années. J'sais pas si tu te souviens, il avait été dessiné de—
Ouais, y avait ce truc avec Navo aussi, non ?
Ouais. Après ça, qu'est-ce qu'y a eu ? C'est dans le podcast Comedy News Weekly que je fais avec Anthony Mirelli. Il est allé voir Dave Chappelle et justement Jon Stewart à Londres.
Et quelqu'un lui a envoyé une photo de Kevin Razy qui a fait une photo avec Dave Chappelle en coulisses.
Ah ouais, d'accord.
Donc Kevin Ra— c'est pas pour moi, Kevin Razy, mais je vais lui donner quelque chose. Je pense que ses intentions de propager le bien sont totalement sincères.
Je l'ai vu dans certaines vidéos, certains thèmes qu'il utilise. Et y a plusieurs phases, je crois, quand t'es humoriste.
Et aujourd'hui, je suis dans une phase assez agréable où j'arrive à apprécier des gens que j'apprécie pas.
Ouais, donc tu apprécies l'effort et les intentions, c'est ça que tu dis.
Je suis allé voir dernièrement, j'ai offert un cadeau à ma mère pour aller voir une humoriste que j'aime pas, qui s'appelle Lise Dion.
La fille, elle a 30 ans de carrière. J'aime pas, j'aime pas ses blagues, j'aime pas ses thèmes, j'aime pas ça.
Mais c'était tellement agréable de voir un show de quelqu'un que t'aimes pas et qui est professionnel parce que tu peux te concentrer sur le talent de quelqu'un.
Tu te dis : « Je sais que j'aime pas ce qu'elle va dire, mais waouh, elle a bien exécuté telle chose, telle chose. » Alors qu'au début, pour exister, j'avais l'impression que je devais trouver que tout était de la merde.
Tu sais, pour sentir que j'étais mieux que les autres, fallait que je trouve que les autres, c'était de la merde. Donc j'ai chié sur à peu près tout le monde.
J'ai dit de la merde sur à peu près tout le monde.
Ouais, pour le coup, je le fais un peu en rigolant hein, mais je, voilà, je respecte toujours l'effort, évidemment.
Ah oui, oui, excuse-moi, je voulais pas t'exposer toi. C'est juste que ça m'a fait penser à— et c'était en plus une bonne vanne.
Et maintenant que je t'ai dit ça, c'est horrible ce que je fais parce que ça t'oblige à dire : « Non, je voulais pas vraiment dire ça.
» Et je t'expose totalement. Mais bon, c'était juste pour rebondir sur autre chose. Et voilà.
Et j'ai reçu dans les frères Taloche que j'avais reçus et j'aurai du respect éternel pour Vincent Taloche qui était venu dans mon late show.
Et il avait dit à la journaliste qui l'avait contacté pour l'inviter, il avait dit : « Je sais que Dan aime pas ce qu'on fait, mais je vais venir quand même.
» Il était venu, puis j'avais demandé, j'ai dit : « Est-ce qu'on peut en parler ? Parce que ce que t'as dit, je trouve ça tellement beau et grand.
J'aimerais en parler. » Il dit : « Pas de problème. » Et on avait terminé avec un concours de je te tiens par la barbichette pour qu'il puisse me mettre une claque.
Et j'avais expliqué ça. J'ai dit que je trouvais ça classe et que quand j'étais plus jeune, je considérais que ce que je trouvais moi pas drôle était de la merde et c'était débile comme façon de penser, je trouve.
J'espère que tous les Français qui nous écoutent pensent maintenant que toutes les émissions belges se terminent par « Je te tiens, tu me tiens par la barbichette ».
Regarde, ce sera mieux que des Doigts dans le slip ou encore Éric Zemmour. Les Français n'auront plus leur sonde télévision à donner.
C'est vrai. Ils seront jaloux après ce podcast.
En gros, c'est pas compliqué. T'as deux choix si tu veux faire ta promo en France : aller te faire insulter chez Ruquier ou aller te faire humilier chez Hanouna, ou aller genre vivre dans les années 80 chez Ardisson. Donc—
Ouais, c'est un peu ça.
C'est détestable. Mais, et donc juste avant qu'il mette une claque, il m'a dit : « Celle-là, elle est pour mon frère.
» Et ça m'a sincèrement touché parce que je me suis dit : « Putain, moi qui faisais des vannes en me croyant meilleur que les autres, clairement, j'ai fait de la peine à quelqu'un qui fait un effort sincère.
» Et dans le cas des Taloche qui réussit, ils font plaisir à des gens depuis 25, 30 ans. Je trouve ça déplacé ce que j'ai fait.
Aujourd'hui, je le fais plus.
Mais qu'est-ce que tu as fait ? Tu parles de quoi là exactement ?
Oh bah en gros, je— j'étais chez NRJ à l'époque, puis je faisais des chroniques sur le fait que les Taloche, c'était de la merde, tu vois.
Et que les trouver drôles, c'était d'être stupide, tu vois.
Ouais, donc tu rigolais d'eux et pas avec eux et t'étais un peu dans le mépris, dans l'humiliation.
Vu que moi, je les trouvais pas drôles, je considérais qu'ils étaient stupides. Parce qu'il y a ce côté-là avec l'humour.
Si tu trouves pas quelque chose drôle, tu te sens supérieur à ceux qui trouvent ça drôle. C'est une mauvaise façon de penser.
C'est une erreur de la pensée. Y a des styles d'humour. Moi, à l'époque, Mr. Bean, je le trouvais nul. J'ai regardé Les Vacances de Mr.
Bean l'année passée, j'ai hurlé de rire. Y a des choses qui— regarde, l'humour, c'est une science exacte. Ça te fait rire, c'est drôle.
Ça te fait pas rire, c'est drôle pour d'autres.
C'est— ouais, j'ai cru comprendre que c'était un peu ton cheval de bataille, étant— c'est peut-être un peu un truc américain, faudrait que tu me dises, mais
j'ai aussi l'impression que tu vois un peu la comédie comme une science technique
plutôt que comme un truc un peu, un truc de clown quoi.
Genre, je sais que t'as lu beaucoup de choses sur le sujet.
Donc j'ai aussi un peu l'impression que tu— voilà, que c'est une conception peut-être plus américaine, et c'est différent par rapport à ce qu'on voit en francophonie d'habitude.
Oui, oui, je peux comprendre. Beaucoup d'humoristes font ça par instinct et n'aiment pas se faire dire qu'ils répondent à des règles mathématiques. Parce que t'as l'impression d'être un génie si tu le fais par instinct.
Et si on réduit ça à des règles mathématiques, t'as juste l'impression d'avoir eu de la chance de les comprendre. Mais qu'est-ce qui fait que tu peux expliquer le génome humain par la science et pas le rire par la science ?
Fuck you, tu vois. Y a des techniques—
C'est ça, faut être rationnel au bout d'un moment.
Ouais, c'est ça. Y a des techniques. Toi, tu l'as peut-être par instinct. Y a des choses qu'on comprend pas encore, mais ce sont des techniques.
On peut apprendre à quelqu'un à être drôle. Oui, tu peux apprendre à n'importe qui à être plus drôle que ce qu'il est.
J'apprendrai à personne à devenir Jerry Seinfeld, mais j'peux apprendre à n'importe qui à être plus drôle parce qu'il existe des techniques.
Si tu veux même les résumer, y en a 13 principalement et j'peux te les nommer. Et c'est des façons de déclencher un rire parce que le rire se résume à la définition la meilleure qui existe, c'est une transgression bénigne.
Voilà deux mots : transgression bénigne, quelque chose de surprenant qui est pas dommageable. C'est ça le rire.
Mmm-hmm.
Est-ce qu'on peut rire de tout avec des— on s'en bat les couilles. La définition, c'est transgression bénigne. Ce qui est une transgression est une définition différente pour tout le monde.
Ce qui est bénin est une définition différente pour tout le monde. C'est ce qui fait que ce qui fait rire est différent pour tout le monde. That's it.
Je vais peut-être dire une bêtise, mais j'ai toujours eu l'impression, moi, que,
plus y avait un décalage entre le moment où la punchline arrive et le moment où tu comprends la punchline, ou plus ce moment-là est long, plus la blague va être efficace et plus tu vas rigoler fort. Je me trompe ?
Ça s'appelle le stretch.
Ouais.
Oui, c'est technique. En gros, t'as la prémisse, je t'annonce un sujet, puis je le gonfle, je le gonfle, je le gonfle, puis je fais péter une balloune.
Plus je gonfle la balloune, plus quand ça pète, ça fait du bruit. Puis le bruit, c'est le rire. C'est—
Non, non, mais pas entre la prémisse et la punchline, mais le moment où tu dis la punchline et genre je la comprends pas, je mets un moment à comprendre la punchline
et si c'est une milliseconde, je souris un peu.
Mais si c'est une grosse seconde avant que je comprenne la punchline, là, je vais rigoler très très fort.
C'est, ça répond à toutes les règles mathématiques, c'est-à-dire que ta surprise est plus grande, tout simplement.
Mmm-hmm.
C'est que tu fais comme : « Ça fait aucun sens. Oh ! » Et y a un double aspect avec ça, c'est la surprise a été plus grande, le stretch a été plus long, donc t'as gonflé la balloune plus longtemps.
Et y a aussi un bête détail, là, mais
dans... Et putain, j'ai oublié le nom. Je te l'enverrai par mail le nom si tu veux glisser
le— y a un DVD sur le rire qui a été fait par un, je crois que c'est un Néerlandais, mais qui explique, ça a été filmé au Théâtre du Rond-Point à Paris, si ma mémoire est bonne.
Néerlandais, donc Dave.
Dave ou encore le joueur de football Robin. C'est les deux Néerlandais que je—
Ouais, ou Guillaume Dange.
Mais le fait de comprendre une référence pointue va te faire rire plus fort parce qu'il y a avec un sentiment de supériorité.
Tu vois quelqu'un glisser—
C'est ça.
...sur une peau de banane.
Moi, j'irai pas glisser sur la peau de banane, donc ça me fait rire. Et tu remarqueras que si tu vas au cinéma et t'as quelqu'un qui fait une blague et dont la punchline est l'État de l'Iowa
et une référence aux pommes de terre, parce qu'en Iowa, ils font beaucoup de pommes de terre.
Les trois personnes dans la salle qui le comprennent vont faire comme : « Ha ha ha ha ! » Et c'est le problème de connaître les techniques d'humour.
C'est moi, quand j'entends ça, j'ai juste envie de t'envoyer une sarbacane de tranquillisant pour cheval et de faire : « Fuck you ».
La personne qui rit pas parce qu'elle a trouvé ça drôle, mais qui rit parce qu'elle veut montrer aux autres qu'elle a compris la blague.
Meurs étouffé dans ton vomi de « je ris de ma propre vanne », quoi.
OK, OK. Donc tu crois que c'est un truc réfléchi et pas un truc spontané, quoi ?
Bah en fait, bah voilà, tu viens d'être plus intelligent que moi. Je crois que c'est spontané, donc j'ai pas de raison de leur en vouloir. Voilà.
Bah voilà.
C'est très humiliant, mais t'as raison.
C'est ça que j'essaie de comprendre. Mais OK, c'est cool, parfait. On va conclure là-dessus, Dan Gagnon.
Mais c'est ça qui a de beau et c'est ça que j'aime bien avec les questions. Et je te trouve très doué dans ce que tu fais et je le dis au premier degré. C'est—
Ah merci.
...le problème de la plupart des intervieweurs, c'est que la question est meilleure que la réponse. Ta question doit toujours être moins intéressante que la réponse.
Et le « pourquoi est-ce que tu leur en veux ? »
Avec moi, c'est facile.
Non, mais elle est, non, mais elle est géniale la question. Parce qu'une fois que tu dis : « Pourquoi tu leur en veux ?
» tu m'obliges à me rendre compte que ce que je dis est stupide et j'fais : « Ah ben oui, t'as raison. » Donc soit je dis : « T'as raison » et j'suis genre stupide, mais pas trop,
soit j'te dis : « Non, t'as tort » et là, j'suis plein de mauvaise foi et j'suis français.
Donc, tu vois, c'est une blague.
Et écoute, je rigole encore plus fort parce que c'est du mépris.
À fond, à fond. Mais j'en parle aujourd'hui parce qu'on a enregistré un numéro de Comedy News Weekly avec Anthony aujourd'hui et j'ai dit : « C'est fou.
Pour moi, les Français, c'est comme les Américains. Je trouve ça incroyable qu'autant d'individus fantastiques, intéressants, drôles puissent créer une communauté qu'on déteste autant.
» Si quelqu'un dit : « J'suis américain » ou « J'suis français », le premier réflexe de tous les gens qui sont ni français ni américains, c'est : « Urgh ».
Ouais, c'est un peu ça.
C'est la première,
c'est la première réaction. Tu fais : « Alors moi, je viens de France. » Tu fais : « Nah, fuck you. » Et je sais pas exactement d'où ça vient parce que, j'veux dire, les Français que moi, j'connais, la plupart ce
sont des humoristes, mais
un gars comme Yacine Belhousse, y a personne de plus adorable.
Yacine Belhousse, Navo, c'est un cerveau. C'est le seul cerveau fluffy qui existe. Navo, t'as envie de t'endormir sur l'oreiller.
J'connais pas le,
j'connais pas l'histoire et les origines de Yacine et Navo, mais pour le coup, mon expérience à moi, c'est que les Français les plus
géniaux que j'connais, c'est ceux qui sont arrivés, qui ont eu la nationalité un peu plus tard que les autres et qui sont pas vraiment autant français
à 300 % que les autres.
Mais en fait, tu dois jamais avoir de la fierté. C'est comme être fier d'être beau.
Ouais, ouais.
Sois fier d'avoir du style.
Être fier d'avoir les cheveux blonds, tu vois, ouais.
C'est ça. Sois pas fier d'avoir les yeux bleus. T'sais, j'veux dire, les deux bonnes personnes ont baisé pour que t'aies les yeux bleus.
C'est des chromosomes, ça n'a rien à voir avec toi. Sois fier de ton style, sois fier de ta conversation, sois fier de tes connaissances, sois fier de tes échecs même pour y revenir.
Ouais, ouais. C'est comme, enfin, je trouve qu'il y a pas énormément de sens à être fier de, t'sais, même quand ils te parlent de la culture française, des Lumières, 17e siècle, tout ça, ils étaient là, mais,
mais enfin, quel rapport avec toi quoi ? Enfin, c'est—
Est-ce que t'es Victor Hugo ? Non. Then fuck you and shut the fuck up.
Top. C'est Doug Stanhope, qui est un des meilleurs... en fait, c'est potentiellement, parce que c'est dans le top 5 des meilleurs humoristes au monde, je suis absolument convaincu.
Donc, Doug Stanhope, si vous le connaissez pas, allez le voir. Vous allez pas mal être choqué au début, mais suivez-le.
C'est lui qui, pour moi, est un des meilleurs. Y a le meilleur sketch de tous les temps, c'est lui. C'est sur le fait que Dieu existe.
Et c'est sur un show qui est sur Netflix. Allez le voir. Je vais pas le spoiler, ce serait stupide. Il va le raconter mieux que moi.
C'est à la fin de son special sur Netflix. C'est le meilleur bit de tous les temps. Et lui, il commençait un de ses shows en disant : « Comme ça, vous le savez, à un moment du spectacle, vous allez me détester.
Mais voyez ce spectacle comme une bataille. Suivez-moi dans la bataille, on va perdre des gens, mais restez avec moi, on va se rendre jusqu'au bout.
» Et il essaie vraiment
de développer plein de choses. Et il disait ça à un moment donné, il disait : « Les Américains ont un sens de la fierté sur la Deuxième Guerre mondiale qui est pas justifié à partir du moment où t'as pas tenu de fusil en Normandie, tu vois.
» Y a quelqu'un qui dit : « Oh yeah, we won World War II. » Fais : « Vraiment ? On a gagné la Deuxième Guerre mondiale ?
Parce que moi, quand je me suis réveillé de mon coma éthylique pour avoir bu un Jägermeister de trop, tout ce que je me souviens, c'est qu'on a regardé ESPN puis qu'on s'est branlé en regardant la présentatrice avant de jouer à la Xbox, tu vois.
» Ces fiertés qui appartiennent à d'autres—
Ouais
...devraient te rendre fier des autres et pas de toi-même.
Et que quand tu dis ça, ça rend un truc particulièrement évident, c'est que y a une grosse différence entre la comédie outre-Atlantique et en Europe.
Et quand je dis en Europe, je veux surtout dire la comédie francophone, et aussi un peu le Royaume-Uni, parce que je connais pas trop—
Tu connais moins d'humoristes polonais, j'imagine.
Ouais, c'est ça, ouais.
Mais une grosse différence, c'est que,
outre-Atlantique, on n'hésite pas en fait à aborder des sujets super sérieux, super dark, à faire des trucs plus complexes, à réfléchir ensemble avec le public, alors que en Europe, ce sera un peu plus...
T'sais, les Américains ont un peu ce cliché des humoristes européens comme, t'sais, avec des props, avec des perruques, voilà, donc beaucoup plus d'accessoires, des gros accents, des trucs comme ça.
Donc c'est vrai. C'est juste dire que en Europe, on est un peu plus dans les blagues prout patapouf et que—
C'est juste que les intellectuels ont été ailleurs. Les intellectuels ont été dans le théâtre, beaucoup. Déjà, le one man show en France descend du théâtre, puis du seul en scène, puis arrive au one man show.
Et le stand-up aux États-Unis débarque des cabarets, des bars et arrive au one man show. Donc ça vient pas du tout du même point.
Les réflexions sont pas les mêmes. Mais aujourd'hui, y a une globalisation de la farce, entre autres avec Netflix qui fait un travail merveilleux.
Les kids qui voulaient faire du stand-up y a 20 ans, y avait Coluche en avant d'eux. Les kids qui veulent faire du stand-up aujourd'hui, ils ont le monde.
Donc les références sont les mêmes, donc ça change.
Mmh. Et 'fin, j'ai l'impression que ça bénéficie plus à la comédie en France que l'inverse, non ?
Non,
je suis pas d'accord parce que aux États-Unis, à ce moment-là, ils vont aussi s'ouvrir plus.
Aux États-Unis, y avait une fermeture totalement sur le fait de faire un spectacle qui est un concept, de faire un spectacle où y avait un quatrième mur, de faire un...
Alors qu'aujourd'hui, et c'est la plus belle chose que je trouve avec la génération actuelle versus la mienne. Moi, j'ai 35 ans.
Moi, quand j'allais à l'école, soit t'aimais le rock, soit t'aimais le rap. Puis si t'aimais le rock, puis t'aimais une chanson de rap, t'étais Judas, tu vois.
Aujourd'hui, y a au contraire une valorisation du mélange qui est une preuve d'intelligence de la génération qui m'a suivi et merci à eux.
Mais ça arrive en France... y a une question de nombre aussi. Je veux dire, en France, y avait huit humoristes à l'époque, tu vois.
Aujourd'hui, t'en as 7 257. Donc, il va y avoir plus de variété. Et je pense que on va rentrer, et c'est pas encore le cas, je pense qu'on n'est pas encore dedans, mais je crois que
la génération qui est la mienne va permettre à la génération qui arrive de devenir la génération dorée de l'humour français.
Je suis persuadé de ce truc-là. Il va y avoir des gens qui vont sortir, qui vont être des génies comiques, qui vont faire des trucs de fou parce que
ils auront vu, ils auront lu, ils auront regardé des choses en disant : « Ah, en fait, on s'en bat les couilles de tout.
Tout ce qui compte, c'est est-ce que j'ai quelque chose d'intéressant à dire et est-ce que je peux le dire de manière comique ?
» Le reste, on s'en fout. Et t'as encore le choix de faire, je prends l'exemple des Taloche parce que j'en parlais tout à l'heure, de faire des choses dont le seul objectif est de faire rire.
Moi, je trouve que ça a beaucoup de valeur humaine. Les gens viennent et c'est un défouloir, ils se détendent, puis ils sont des meilleures personnes quand ils sortent de ton spectacle parce qu'ils sont détendus.
Mais je pense que, voilà, moi, je valorise plus le mélange entre le discours et l'aspect comique parce que c'est un goût personnel.
Mais les kids aujourd'hui, ils ont accès à tout. Et ceux qui vont arriver, ils vont défoncer le game. Mais je te dis, il faut attendre encore entre trois et cinq ans.
Mais dans trois à cinq ans, check les prochains humoristes français et belges, ils vont tout déchirer à la même hauteur que les Américains et les Québécois.
Moi, c'est mon opinion personnelle.
Ouais. C'est intéressant parce que, donc là, tu nous annonces une génération qui arrive dans trois à cinq ans, mais
à côté de ça, si on regarde la génération qui est installée, la génération actuelle, on se rend compte grâce justement à cette globalisation, grâce à Netflix et compagnie,
on a l'occasion de se rendre compte que, de tous les sketchs qu'on a entendus ces 10, 20 dernières années,
y a quand même beaucoup de trucs qui sont pompés en Belgique comme en France, sur Jerry Seinfeld, Eddie Murphy et compagnie.
Mais je dis c'est pas grave. Je veux dire, c'est quelque chose qui doit pas être fait, pomper des vannes pour des raisons assez évidentes.
Mais la raison pour laquelle je dis que c'est pas grave, c'est que ça, c'est fini, plus aujourd'hui. Y a quelques personnes qui survivent.
Je disais Malik Bentalha qui survit. T'as Kader Aoun qui a produit Jamel, qui a encore le Paname à Paris, qui s'est pris d'ailleurs la tête avec Mike Ward sur Internet y a pas très, très longtemps—
Il produit le Burger Quiz en ce moment, donc on peut pas dire que ça va mal pour lui.
Tu te fous de ma gueule, c'est Kader Aoun qui produit le Burger Quiz ?
Si je dis pas de bêtises, ouais. On peut checker, attends. Avec Alain Chabat.
OK, non, non, non. Donc, il a produit le Burger Quiz au tout début en 2001 et 2002, mais la saison actuelle de 2018, non, il est pas aux commandes, non.
J'ai dit une bêtise.
OK. Et moi, j'ai une absence de respect absolument totale. Pas pour des gens qui ont pas— ça peut arriver. Et puis en France, y avait un régime qui faisait en sorte que c'était pas mal vu de pomper des vannes.
C'est ça. Mais précisément parce que personne ne le savait. Donc comment est-ce que tu peux en vouloir à quelqu'un si y a pas de preuves, si y a pas de traces ?
Oui, mais personne le savait. Puis vu que personne le savait, tout le monde savait qu'il y en a qui le faisaient, puis c'était OK.
Aujourd'hui, pour moi, si aujourd'hui, t'écris un nouveau show et que tu pompes des vannes, fuck you, t'as pas d'excuses.
Ouais, mais complètement. Mais justement, je pense qu'on, 'fin, on parlait de Malik Bentalha, mais je pense que lui, justement, dans ce qu'il a vendu à Netflix, il reste des trucs pompés.
Ça, je comprends pas. Et je comprends. Encore une fois, t'as le droit d'avoir fait des erreurs. Moi, j'en ai fait 2 000, des erreurs et je trouve que
vouloir planter les gens qui se, qui ont fait des erreurs, c'est vraiment une manière d'essayer de se montrer plus vertueux.
Et tu parles plus de toi que tu parles des autres, tu vois.
Mmm-hmm. Pour le coup, le gars qui l'a dénoncé est anonyme, donc voilà, c'est encore assez... c'est CopyComic, la chaîne YouTube.
Oui, oui. Mais je comprends qu'il soit anonyme. T'as vu les réactions que ça cause ?
D'office, il serait déjà mort.
Lui, je trouve, a fait un rôle très intéressant pour la comédie en France. Maintenant qu'il a annoncé tout ça, maintenant que tu sais qu'il existe, maintenant que c'est acquis pour tout le monde que faut pas faire ça, ne le fais pas.
Mais si aujourd'hui, tu le fais, t'as plus d'excuses. Avant,
et puis ce sera pas populaire comme opinion, mais je pense qu'avant, t'avais des excuses à le faire parce que c'était dans un... y avait un... non, c'est pas t'avais des excuses, mais—
Y avait un contexte, quoi
...sans le justifier, je comprends pourquoi tu le faisais. Voilà. Je pense que ça ne se fait pas.
Mmm-hmm.
Mais je comprends pourquoi tu le faisais. Aujourd'hui, ça ne se fait pas et je comprendrais pas pourquoi tu le fais.
Je crois effectivement, y a parmi les gens que tu as invités pour ton podcast à toi, Dan Gagnon gratuitement—
Oui
...dans les dernières années. Y avait Yacine Belhousse qui a fait ça un petit moment très rapidement.
Et y avait Walter qui est belge donc, qui s'est fait choper par CopyComic aussi.
Je sais pas, il s'en est remis, lui, ou il est complètement—
Walter, je travaille avec lui. J'ai travaillé avec lui pour l'écriture de son deuxième spectacle. J'ai pas fait grand-chose, pour être tout à fait honnête.
Walter a un talent exceptionnel. C'est un conteur comique de génie. Il a effectivement fait une erreur. Il a dû s'en expliquer.
Ça l'a affecté. Moi, un jour, on s'est parlé puis il m'a dit : « Qu'est-ce que tu dis aux gens quand ils te parlent de CopyComic ?
» Je dis : « Exactement la même chose que je te dis à toi. Je pense que t'aurais pas dû le faire. Je pense que c'était une erreur.
Je pense que ça se fait pas. Je suis capable de comprendre pourquoi tu le fais. Je suis capable de comprendre la logique qui t'a amené à le faire plutôt, mais t'as tellement pas besoin de ça, mec ».
Son deuxième show est tellement plus drôle que son premier. Je comprends pas pourquoi il l'a fait, mais moi, je lui donne le droit à avoir fait cette erreur-là.
Je lui donne le droit à l'oubli. Et il a pas tué des gens. Il a copié des vannes. À un moment, il pensait que c'était pas grave de le faire.
De la même manière qu'un cuisinier pense que choper des recettes qu'il a déjà vues puis faire sa propre création, ça demeure sa propre création.
Je suis pas d'accord avec la façon de penser. C'est pas comment moi, je pense. Je comprends comment lui, il a pensé. Puis là, il revient avec un deuxième spectacle.
Et honnêtement, si vous avez vu les trucs de CopyComic, puis vous dites : « Ah, c'est con, je le trouvais drôle, mais il copie des blagues », allez voir son nouveau show.
Le gars est hilarant.
Ouais, non, mais ça résume bien tout, carrément.
Et il est tellement plus drôle. Il est tellement plus personnel avec son stock. Je crois que c'était une erreur. Je crois que t'as le droit de faire une erreur.
Je crois qu'il a prouvé qu'il était plus drôle que son erreur. Et donc, ce qui pose encore la question : pourquoi t'as fait ça ?
You're fucking hilarious.
Mmm-hmm. Ouais, je veux juste revenir sur, tu faisais ton Late Show ici en Belgique, et ça s'est arrêté, je crois, en 2016, si je ne dis pas de bêtises.
Et à la fin de ton Late Show, tu annonçais que tu allais partir et quitter la Belgique et partir vivre au Canada. Ça s'est pas trop passé comme ça, en fait, hein, parce que t'es resté encore pendant un an, un an et demi, deux ans.
Ouais.
Et puis en gros, si je comprends bien, tu passes moite-moite, tu fais moite-moite Canada-Belgique, six mois Belgique, six mois Québec.
C'était l'objectif, mais ça a encore changé. Pour l'instant, je fais 10 jours au Canada, quatre jours en Belgique parce que j'ai continué avec
69 minutes sans chichis, parce que j'aime vraiment bien les équipes et j'ai du plaisir à faire l'émission.
Mais en ce moment, en fait, c'est que ma carrière est encore en Belgique pour l'instant, mais là, je devais faire une quatrième tournée en quatre ans en
2019 et je l'ai reportée parce que je veux écrire puis je veux commencer à avoir une carrière au Québec.
Donc, je me suis créé aussi un studio dans le sous-sol. J'ai acheté une maison au Canada, donc j'ai un studio dans mon sous-sol.
Ça, je fais des pilotes, j'essaie de produire ça et de présenter ça aux émissions de télé. Mon objectif, en gros, c'est de jamais quitter ma maison ni mon pyjama.
Parfait. J'approuve.
Mais je vais continuer de faire des shows pour la Belgique. Et donc en 2020, j'ai déjà une tournée, j'ai déjà des dates là qui—
C'est ça
...des salles qui sont bookées pour 2020, pour faire mon nouveau show en Belgique, mais ça va être moins— je ferai plus un show par année comme je le faisais.
OK, OK. Maintenant, j'allais te demander ce que tu fais en fait au Canada, mais si je comprends bien, c'est tu fais des podcasts, tu écris pour ton spectacle en 2020 et ton activité au Québec et tu joues à Hearthstone en pyjama.
Mais j'adore Hearthstone. Hearthstone, si j'étais pas aussi nul, je gagnerais ma vie sur Twitch.
Je disais ça pour la vanne, mais en fait, c'est vrai.
Non, c'est pas la vanne. Je kiffe ce jeu. J'adore, je regarde des vidéos, je suis fan de Trump, de Disguised Toast, de Kibler.
T'es fan de Trump ? C'est ça que t'as dit ?
Trump, c'est un gars qui fait des vidéos, c'est un bon joueur de Hearthstone qui fait des vidéos. The Trump, Disguised Toast, Kibler, c'est trois gars que je regarde.
T'as le Deck Doctor aussi.
Le cliché sur les streamers Twitch, c'est que ils te vendent des vape rigs pour te vendre des cigarettes électroniques tout le temps.
C'est vrai ça ou pas ?
Moi, ce que je regarde, je suis pas sur Twitch, je paye pas, je suis que sur YouTube. Donc c'est des—
OK.
Et y a pas. Mais moi, j'en ai rien à foutre, je te vendrais des— ici, c'est stems.com, ceux qui font des podcasts, c'est une machine pour faire des times chez toi.
Moi, honnêtement, je pourrais te vendre des butt plugs. Je m'en fous, si c'est pour rester chez moi et que c'est du plaisir et que je vends ça aux adultes qui font ce qu'ils veulent.
J'ai jamais pensé que
l'art et l'argent étaient des frères ennemis, tu vois. Cette façon-là de penser que t'as de l'intégrité artistique parce que t'es pauvre ou que t'es une merde parce que t'es riche, je trouve ça débile.
Oui, oui. C'est, c'est bien dit. Ça, c'est clairement un petit peu ton côté américain plutôt que ton côté européen.
Parce que pour le coup, effectivement, y a très fort cette culpabilité de l'argent, surtout en France.
Ben oui.
Et j'écoutais justement le dernier épisode de Nouvelle École, qui vient de s'arrêter, et il conclut en disant : « Mais ah, je suis très content de jamais avoir mis de la publicité parce que
la pub, ça aurait corrompu le truc, l'argent, ça aurait pourri tout le truc.
» Et j'écoutais ça, je me disais : « Mais non, mais pourquoi tu—
Mais de où ? Je veux dire, ça, de l'argent, ça corrompt le truc. Tu l'as payé avec quoi ton fucking micro, ton ordinateur, ta connexion Internet, tes frais ?
Everybody needs fucking money. Tu crois que t'as plus de valeur parce que l'argent, tu le pompes à l'État parce que t'as pas réussi à vendre un spectacle de ta vie ?
T'es ni plus ni moins une merde. Moi, je trouve que artiste, y a quelque chose de tellement honnête et sincère quand des gens considèrent que t'es assez bon pour te donner leur argent de manière volontaire.
Moi, quand je vis avec l'argent que les gens me donnent, moi, mes podcasts, j'ai commencé à les faire sur Patreon.
Donc, en gros, Patreon, c'est, tu peux avoir les trucs gratuits plus tard ou plus tôt et d'autres bonus et des avantages si tu payes.
Les gens font : « Ah, mais ça a toujours été gratuit. Pourquoi tu demandes de l'argent ? » Because food is not—
C'est ça
...free, motherfucker. Parce que c'est mon métier, c'est mon talent, puis j'ai envie de vivre avec ma passion. Et donc, je veux vivre avec ma passion.
Donc moi, ce que je te dis, c'est la façon dont j'essaie de te divertir. Est-ce que tu considères que ça vaut de l'argent ?
Sinon, ne me paye pas. Je te tends pas la main, je te force pas. C'est pas une taxe. C'est un paiement que je te propose en échange du divertissement.
Et puis Dieu sait si le divertissement, il y en a gratuitement partout sur Internet. Donc tous ceux qui me payent sur le Patreon, on a genre quelques centaines de dollars par mois.
Mais ça, c'est une de mes plus grandes fiertés. Des gens qui disent : « Tu sais quoi ? De tout le divertissement gratuit qui existe, je considère qu'il y a moins de valeur que toi de payer parce que j'aime ce que tu fais.
» Et j'ai un vrai affect pour les gens qui me soutiennent. Et c'est pas fake, genre de : « Ah, mes fans ». C'est pas des fans, c'est des gens qui veulent que je continue puis qui m'encouragent. Ben—
C'est le soutien.
Merci beaucoup, vraiment.
Mh. Ouais, mais on a reçu, dans l'épisode 4 de ce podcast, on a reçu Patrick Beja, qui vit justement de Patreon.
Il reçoit 2 500 $ par épisode et il fait un podcast hebdomadaire. Donc c'est, voilà, y a petit à petit un début de changement en France.
C'est volontaire. C'est ça que je trouve merveilleux. Moi, des podcasts, j'en fais depuis fucking longtemps. J'ai commencé à en faire, les premiers tests que j'ai faits, ça doit faire genre y a sept ans.
Je veux dire, tu m'as dit que y a sept ans, les podcasts, on te regardait en disant : « Pourquoi est-ce que aucune radio ne veut de toi ?
», tu vois. Puis aujourd'hui, quand je vois qu'il y en a qui arrivent à vivre de ça, j'ai l'impression de vivre la même époque que pour les youtubeurs il y a deux, trois ans, mais genre pour les gens moches, j'imagine, je sais pas.
On laisse passer, tout va bien.
Mais honnêtement, si on peut vivre des podcasts, moi, je vais passer ma vie à essayer de divertir les gens en pyjama dans mon sous-sol avec mon micro, tu vois.
Mais c'est ton business, je comprends bien. Tu joues à Hearthstone et puis tu fais des podcasts sur la comédie en pyjama.
Et en plus de ça, il me semble que tu as teasé rapidement. Alors, je sais pas si tu peux déjà en parler, mais tu as teasé dernièrement dans Comedy News Weekly.
On l'a pas encore dit, mais c'est ton podcast hebdomadaire que tu fais avec Anthony Mirelli, où vous parlez de l'actu de la comédie.
Yes.
L'actu de la farce. Et dedans, tu as teasé que tu avais prévu un nouveau podcast. Donc tu as Dan Gagnon gratuitement, Comedy News Weekly, le podcast avec ta maman.
Et maintenant, un nouveau podcast que tu as plus ou moins annoncé. Tu disais que c'était un truc en rapport avec un projet de loi au Canada.
Oui.
C'est quoi ? Il se passe quoi ?
Ben, c'est mignon comment tu le dis, mais la plupart de ces podcasts sont inactifs. Donc ça a l'air de quelqu'un de très occupé.
Ouais, mais tu les as pas tués officiellement, c'est pour ça.
Mais, en fait, le 17 octobre 2018, la weed est devenue légale au Canada. Et—
D'accord, OK
...dans cette optique, on a essayé de faire un podcast avec mon épouse qui s'appelle Weed With Wife. Et le titre est exactement le concept.
En gros, on fume avec ma femme, puis on va faire un épisode par semaine et ça va démarrer début novembre.
Et quoi, vous allez genre vous enregistrer en train de regarder Beavis and Butt-Head sur MTV, c'est ça ?
Non, on discute. On discute en disant : « Salut, comment ça va ? Bla bla bla. Bon, le podcast, c'est ça cette semaine. » Et puis là, on se pose des questions.
Mais c'est juste une conversation comme on aurait. C'est vraiment un micro dans la chambre de deux personnes qui fument de la weed et qui se parlent en tant que deux personnes amoureuses, tu vois.
Donc c'est vraim— y a un côté excessivement voyeur. Est-ce que ça va être intéressant ou pas ? J'en ai pas la moindre idée.
Mais pour moi, la définition—
Ouais, c'est intéressant.
Ouais, c'est ça. Pour moi, la définition d'un bon podcast, quand j'interview des gens, le commentaire que je préfère entendre à la fin, c'est quand je dis à l'invité : « Est-ce que t'as passé un bon moment ?
» Puis qu'il me dit : « Ah oui, mais je sais pas si ça va intéresser quelqu'un d'autre. » Ça, pour moi, c'est la clé de la perfection.
Parce que ce que ça veut dire, c'est : j'ai pas réfléchi à essayer de plaire, j'ai juste été moi-même. Et pour moi, y a que ça qui est intéressant.
Oui. Je repense à un truc là comme ça. Je me rappelle, j'étais venu, je crois que c'était y a un an et demi.
C'était genre la deuxième fois que je venais te voir en spectacle. C'était au Kings of Comedy Club à Ixelles.
Et je me suis ramené comme ça un soir où y avait pas énormément de monde dans la salle. Et j'me souviens que c'était une soirée super dark.
En fait, je venais pour de la farce et c'est devenu super dark. 'Fin, c'était genre moins de 48 heures après que ta femme ait dû se faire traiter aux urgences.
Ouiii, c'était—
Suite à, y avait une histoire de,
d'interruption de grossesse. J'me souviens que j'étais complètement sur le cul pendant toute la soirée parce que y avait genre, tu vois,
moins de 48 heures après que ce soit produit, toute une histoire vraiment super sombre, super dark, c'est sanglant, les larmes et tout.
Et t'as réussi à faire un show, genre moins de 48 heures après, avec bon, voilà, les trucs dark, mais en plus de ça, bon, tu nous tenais en haleine, y avait des vannes sur les infirmières, sur le staff et tout.
Et j'étais sur le cul parce que t'arrivais à faire un spectacle très rapidement. Du coup, c'était presque de l'impro parce que c'était pas longtemps après les événements.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui te vient spontanément, cette capacité à l'impro, à être comme ça sur scène ?
Ça, c'était à la douleur, pour être vraiment précis, parce que ça s'était passé, en gros, mon épouse avait fait une grossesse extra-utérine et on a dû,
on avait été à l'hôpital d'urgence, a dû se faire opérer, se faire tirer une trompe de Fallope parce que c'était pas viable.
Et donc, c'est vraiment, elle a fait une hémorragie. C'était horrible. Et ça, c'était dans la nuit du dimanche au lundi.
Le lundi matin, moi, je sais que je joue le lundi soir au Comedy Club et je dis : « Putain, mais je sais pas comment je vais réussir à être drôle ».
Et j'ai la chance d'être marié avec quelqu'un d'absolument merveilleux, qui me connaît, qui me comprend et qui accepte vraiment très très fort et qui valorise qui je suis.
Et elle me dit : « Est-ce que t'as envie d'en parler ? » Je fais : « Putain, ça te dérange pas ? » Elle me dit : « En gros, je te connais.
Je sais que toi, la plupart des gens appelleraient un pote et iraient leur raconter. Toi, tu vas pas le faire. J'arrive pas à parler de cette manière-là ».
Moi, j'ai plus de facilité à parler sur ça. Et je sais que je sonne comme un gros douche bag, trou du cul.
Non, je comprends.
C'est juste vrai. De toute façon, tu l'as vu, tu le sais que c'est vrai et que c'est sincère. Et j'me dis : « J'vais aller me défouler ».
Mais ça venait d'un point de douleur, mais d'un point d'amour aussi. Et y a chez moi un amour du stand-up qui est de partir de quelque chose de douloureux puis rendre ça comique.
Je savais que j'allais pas réussir à rendre ça hilarant la première journée, mais à partir du moment où t'es juste, dans quoi que ce soit que tu fasses d'ailleurs, à partir du moment où t'es sincère, que ça vient d'un point d'amour,
ça ne peut pas être mauvais.
Ça peut pas être 100 % mauvais. Et tu dois juste faire confiance au fait que si tu décris avec justesse quelque chose que t'as ressenti avec force, les gens devant toi vont ressentir avec compassion quelque chose qui leur semble juste.
Et c'est ça que j'ai choisi de faire. En y repensant, je le ferais pas de la même manière parce que j'ai un peu l'impression d'avoir pris les gens en otage, ceux qui s'y attendaient pas.
Ouais, je me souviens que tu t'arrêtais pas de t'excuser d'avoir fait ça et tu demandais aux gens : « Si vous voulez, voilà, j'ai déjà des spectacles en réserve, donc si vous voulez, je vous en fais un maintenant, y a pas de souci ».
En fait, ce que j'ai fait, c'est que— j'aurais dû le dire au début. J'aurais dû l'annoncer en disant : « Ceux qui sont venus pour tel truc ».
Et ce que j'ai choisi de faire à la fin, donc j'ai parlé de ça pendant 45 minutes, effectivement, et c'est devenu 10, 12 minutes dans mon spectacle, au final, parce que c'est—
Putain, le point du stand-up de base, c'est d'être le plus vrai possible.
Et y a pas grand-chose de plus vrai que quelqu'un qui a pas dormi de la nuit parce qu'il a vécu ça. Et c'est pas moi qui ai vécu ça, c'est elle qui a vécu ça.
Ouais, t'étais moins avec elle à ce moment-là.
C'est ça, exactement. C'est ça. C'était pas agréable pour moi, mais putain, c'est quand même pas, je veux dire, moi, on m'a pas charcuté.
Ouais. Et je me souviens que la soirée s'est conclue plus ou moins au moment où tu demandais au public de surtout ne pas le répéter.
Tu disais : « S'il vous plaît, gardez ça pour vous » et tout. Je suis revenu pour voir le vrai spectacle quelques mois plus tard.
Et là, c'était carrément : « Eh les gars, ma meuf a eu une IVG. Lol ».
Mais c'est parce que je l'ai fait. Au début, je l'ai pas fait en calcul. Vraiment, je l'ai pas fait en calcul. Je veux dire, y a plein de choses que tu peux— c'était pas un calcul, c'était une expulsion, littéralement.
Sans vouloir faire de mauvais putain jeu de mots dans le groupe sémantique là. Mais, et après, je me suis dit : « En fait, y a quelque chose de beau ».
Bah cette journée-là, je me sentais un peu mal. Donc au bout des 45 minutes, je dis à tout le monde : « Moi, j'ai plombé l'ambiance.
On va faire une pause. Si vous avez envie de rigoler, je vous fais un autre spectacle ». On a fait une pause. Les gens sont revenus.
Y a deux filles qui m'ont dit : « Je suis désolée, nous, on se casse, ça nous a vraiment démoli. On a déjà vécu quelque chose comme ça ».
Et je fais : « Honnêtement, je suis sincèrement désolé ». Et voilà. Et donc j'essaie maintenant, en show, je l'annonçais, je préparais le public parce sinon, je les choquais trop fort.
Et c'est pas mon but, moi, de choquer les gens. Mon but, c'est que les gens soient divertis et idéalement, en entendant des choses pas trop stupides.
Mais y avait ce côté-là où c'est pas un gars qui raconte ça d'habitude. Tu vois, c'est pas, c'est—
C'est ça, ouais.
Je le faisais pour elle, pour mon épouse, pour moi, c'était ma façon de le vivre parce que c'est, encore une fois, le stand-up, j'ai de la chance que ce soit dans,
dans mes tripes, dans, littéralement, c'est dans mes entrailles.
Ce truc-là me fait du bien à fond. J'adore. Et je trouve ça
jouissif, littéralement. Et là, pour le coup, c'était de peut-être passer un des trucs les plus durs que j'avais vécu, qu'elle avait vécu, mais bon, moi aussi, pour moi, c'était pas égal.
C'était thérapeutique.
Exactement, avec sincérité.
Et y a toujours ce côté-là où tout le monde va dire la même chose, mais t'as le premier, t'as Richard Pryor qui a raconté qu'il est né dans un bordel, sa grand-mère qui l'a élevé, qui le battait, puis sa mère était une prostituée.
Puis après ça, t'as 250 000 personnes qui ont fait ça, mais c'est pas un risque quand t'es le deuxième.
Mmm-hmm. Mmm-hmm.
Et c'est ce que j'essaie. Pour une fois, y avait un côté et j'espère que je sonnerai pas comme quelqu'un qui a essayé d'utiliser une situation désagréable pour mon épouse.
Puis je pense que quand t'as vu le show, ça se voit que ça—
Ouais, ouais, pour l'avoir vu, c'était vraiment super sincère.
Merci, parce que si c'était pas sincère, je l'aurais plus jamais refait— après, parce que t'as pas envie d'exploiter la misère des, déjà la tienne, mais celle des autres encore moins.
Mais y avait un côté tellement jouissif de dire genre : « OK, là, y a pas de calcul. Je m'expose comme l'art veut que tu t'exposes dans un but positif.
Et je pense que— ben, t'as vu les deux versions. Toi, t'as vu la première fois, puis t'as vu après quand c'est travaillé.
C'est ça. Ouais, ouais.
Je pense que— et je peux me tromper, puis tu pourras me corriger. Puis de toute façon, le show, il va passer à la RTBF.
Vous pouvez l'acheter en audio, il existe là, sur Bandcamp. Il faut même— j'ai su après qu'il y avait une passe pour l'avoir gratuitement.
Maintenant, c'est minimum 1 €, tu donnes ce que tu veux, mais je crois que si tu fais juste le streamer, c'est gratuit. Donc, faites ce que vous voulez.
C'est ça qui me rendait mal à l'aise à chaque fois. On en parlera après quand on fera le plug.
Mais effectivement, pendant longtemps, j'étais là : « Mais does he know ? »
Mais c'est pas— moi, c'est pas grave. J'aime bien distribuer ce que je fais parce que ce que je propose est le meilleur de ce que je suis capable de faire, que ce soit bon ou pas, que t'aimes ou pas.
Mais je te promets que c'est sincèrement la meilleure chose que je suis capable de faire. Et—
Non, juste pour revenir à la soirée dont on parle.
Je pense que le mood,
il est ironiquement positif et plein d'amour. Et je— c'est peut-être la seule phrase intelligente que j'ai vraiment dite dans ma vie là, mais je pense que la tristesse a ça de beau qu'elle te rend humble et te rapproche.
Mmm-hmm.
Tes meilleurs amis, c'est sûr que t'as au moins vécu quelque chose de difficile, puis ils étaient là pour toi. Les liens les plus forts viennent d'un point de joie, mais souvent d'un point de tristesse.
Les gens qui ont été là pour toi quand c'était la merde, t'as du respect pour eux, éternel. Et dans 10 ans, ils t'appellent, tu vas les aider.
Et c'est ce que j'essayais de partager parce qu'il y a un côté communion au stand-up. C'est une personne qui parle à 1 000 personnes comme si elle était une personne.
C'est un peu ça, le stand-up. Et je trouve que encore aujourd'hui, de toutes les fois où j'ai essayé d'exprimer la douleur de manière comique, j'ai jamais réussi aussi bien que cette fois-là.
Et je dis pas que c'est réussi, puis je dis pas que vous allez trouver ça drôle. Je dis que toutes les autres fois sont moins réussies que ça.
Au risque d'avoir l'air un peu un connard, je— effectivement, ce soir-là, ça m'a vraiment marqué. Et en plus, tu closurais la soirée en disant : « Mais s'il vous plaît, n'en parlez à personne, ne répétez pas » et tout.
J'étais là : « Mais ouais, it's my thing, c'est mon truc. J'ai le cul-assez de voir ça. » Et après, c'était devenu : « Eh les gars, eh, ma meuf a eu une IVG, ptdr. »
Oui, oui, je comprends. Mais je comprends. Puis je pense que cette soirée-là—
Non, non, non, mais tu peux pas vraiment comme ça hein. J'exagère évidemment.
Mais on est quand même pas loin. Mais là, mais je pense que cette soirée-là, j'étais OK avec parce que le soir, c'était, ben c'était quand même, je veux dire c'est quand même assez bouleversant.
Et je suis rentré en me demandant : « Est-ce que j'ai bien fait ou est-ce que j'ai été un connard qui a exploité ça ?
Est-ce que j'ai été égoïste ? Est-ce que j'ai plombé l'ambiance ? » Parce que j'en avais trois autres shows.
Si je veux faire rire les gens, je veux dire ceux qui viennent me voir, je suis capable de les faire rire. Je dis pas que je suis drôle pour tout le monde, mais c'est mon job.
Je suis bon dans mon job. Je sais ce que je fais. Je ferai pas de fausse humilité. Si je me trouvais nul, j'irais pas faire le masochiste dans des salles chaque année.
Mais je me dis : « J'étais OK avec moi-même en me disant : Au pire, si c'était pas marrant et si c'était mauvais, j'ai la certitude que c'était sincère.
Et ceux qui sont venus dans un petit comedy club pour vivre quelque chose de spécial ont peut-être pas rigolé autant que ce qu'ils croyaient, mais ils ont vécu quelque chose de spécial. »
Ouais, une expérience hein, clairement. Ouais, ouais.
Et ça me fait plaisir que tu dises ça parce que, parce que déjà, au moins, ma femme aura servi à quelque chose.
Elle est pas capable de mettre un bébé au monde, au moins, elle servira à faire une vanne. Je précise qu'elle aime les vannes trash et c'est pour ça que je me permets de les faire parce que je sais que ça la fait rigoler.
Mais ouais, c'était, c'est un des rares moments où j'ai l'impression de faire du vrai stand-up comme mes idoles dans ma vie.
Et je, si j'avais le choix, je vivrais pas ce moment-là. Mais je tiens à préciser que si c'était pas moi qui disais ces mots-là et que j'entendais ça dans un podcast, mon premier réflexe, ce serait de dire à la personne : « Fuck you.
» C'est ça. Mais regarde, c'est peut-être raté la manière dont je le dis, mais je vous promets que c'est sincère. Si vous me croyez pas, fuck you.
Non, mais j'atteste hein. Je valide tout à fait ce que tu dis. Dan, on arrive au bout des 70 minutes qu'on a largement dépassées.
On va un peu plugger toutes tes histoires là, ton—
Excuse-moi, mais c'est très drôle. On arrive tout doucement au bout des 70 minutes qu'on a largement dépassées est excessivement drôle comme phrase.
Ça pourrait faire partie d'un jingle. Tu pourrais le mettre dans le site. Y en a qui mettent des jingles avec des extraits de trucs.
Ça pourrait tout à fait être un des jingles de promo d'émission.
Ouais, on va pluguer un peu.
J'espère. C'est pour ça que j'ai fait ça. Tu te doutes bien, Guillaume Hachez.
Mais évidemment. Alors, vous pouvez donner de l'argent à Dan sur son Bandcamp pour Rose, son quatrième spectacle enregistré.
Honnêtement, je suis pas prêt à assumer le fait que vous donniez de l'argent avant de savoir si vous trouvez ça marrant. Écoutez-
Comment tu fais pour que les gens aillent te voir en spectacle si tu refuses qu'ils apprennent à te connaître avant d'acheter leur place ?
Parce qu'y a plein de trucs gratuits qui sont disponibles. Mon premier show est disponible gratuitement sur YouTube. Il s'appelle L'excellent spectacle de Dan Gagnon.
Checkez-le. Rose, tu peux écouter deux, trois sketchs gratuitement parce que y a ce truc-là de streaming qui est un peu chié de la manière dont on l'a programmé.
Mais après ça, si vous aimez, genre payez-moi, j'aime bien. Y a les podcasts Comedy News Weekly, y en a 100 et quoi ?
107, 108, 110, je sais plus combien on a. Mais vous pouvez écouter littéralement quatre jours de suite non-stop. Ne faites pas ça, vous allez vomir.
Mais si vous aimez bien, y a un Patreon, donc c'est Patreon, donc P-A-T-R-E-O-N, Comedy News Weekly. Vous donnez ce que vous voulez.
Y a des bonus, on essaie de faire le plus de trucs. Moi, le truc que j'essaie de pousser Anthony à faire, c'est proposer aux gens que s'ils donnent un certain montant, on enregistre 10 à 20 minutes où on les insulte
en échange de 10-- genre c'est, y a, ça commence genre à 1, c'est 1, 5, 10, 20, un truc comme ça.
Et je veux que le 10 € par mois, t'aies droit à 20 minutes où on t'envoie un audio, où on t'insulte gratuitement sans aucune bonne raison.
Parce que moi, je paierais ça pour me faire insulter par deux personnes que j'aime bien parce que ça me fait mourir de rire.
C'est un business model prometteur. Donc le Comedy News Weekly-
Tu veux que je te dise quelque chose pour aller un peu plus loin ? Je sais pas si les gens qui écoutent connaissent la logique des roasts.
Un roast, en gros, c'est une personne qui accepte de se faire insulter en public par 10 humoristes qui viennent et qui le démontent.
Puis après ça, y a un droit de réplique. Et à la base, c'était au Friars Club, si ma mémoire est bonne. Et c'était des activités de financement.
Genre t'avais quelqu'un, une figure assez connue qui venait. Tu savais que ses amis allaient l'vanner, tu payais, puis ça allait pour des œuvres de charité.
Quand j'ai eu 30 ans, j'ai demandé un roast à mes amis au Comedy Club. Ça faisait à peu près une semaine que c'était terminé avec ma copine de l'époque où on avait été ensemble pendant neuf ans.
Et mes amis m'ont roasté. C'était d'une violence mon ami. Et en fait, moi, ça me faisait
mourir de rire, mais je m'en suis rendu compte après, j'ai dû aller réconforter mes amis qui connaissaient pas les roasts, qui pensaient que je m'étais fait humilier en public.
Et ça m'a fait encore plus rire que le roast en lui-même. Donc tout ça pour dire que moi, le-
Que t'as un côté masochiste quoi.
Ben c'est juste que pour moi, je l'ai dit souvent, donc c'est pas original, mais être insulté par une blague ou être choqué par une blague, pour moi, c'est comme mourir dans un jeu vidéo.
Ça a l'air grave, mais ça l'est pas. Donc l'humour, pour moi, et c'est pour ça que maintenant, je fais pas vraiment d'humour trash, parce que j'ai pas envie de choquer les gens.
Mon but, c'est de faire rigoler. Mais moi, tu ne peux pas me faire, comme ça. Tu vas pas me vexer avec une blague.
Et je sais que moi, y a deux choses dont je me méfie maintenant, c'est : « T'inquiète, j'aime l'humour noir » et : « T'inquiète, j'vais pas me vexer ».
Ça, plus jamais j'vais croire ces phrases-là parce que ellipse six secondes plus tard, les gens pleurent, ils font une plainte là.
Mais moi, j'ai littéralement zéro limite en humour. J'ai jamais croisé ma limite en humour. Donc vous pouvez me faire des vannes et m'insulter, ça me fait mourir de rire.
Et donc voilà, c'est pour ça que je le propose aux autres. Pour l'instant, y a zéro personne qui l'a demandé. Donc clairement, j'ai des problèmes et on n'est pas nombreux à penser comme moi.
Mais si ça vous fait marrer, vous donnez 10 euros par mois et j'vous fais le 20 minutes d'insultes le plus violent que vous n'ayez jamais entendu de toute votre-
Juste, Dan Gagnon Gratuitement, tu ne le fais plus beaucoup, mais y avait un moment où on avait parlé que ça reprenne un petit peu.
Alors une petite souris m'a dit que tu songeais à faire des interviews de par exemple Guy Home ou des Frères Taloche.
Oui.
Est-ce que ça va se faire, tu crois ?
Honnêtement, je sais pas si je vais le faire, mais je voudrais le faire au Québec aussi, mais au Québec, y en a 50 000 qui font ça, donc j'vois pas trop l'intérêt.
Mon point, c'est juste de-- moi, j'aime ça. Y a rien qui m'intéresse plus que des gens qui parlent. Voilà. J'aime les histoires, donc j'ai juste envie d'avoir des histoires.
C'est pour ça que j'fais un podcast avec ma mère. C'est pour ça que j'fais des podcasts d'interview.
C'est pour ça que tu smokes de la weed en t'écoutant parler.
Idéalement, ma femme parle, j'espère. En tout cas, le pire, c'est que le premier épisode, y a un moment donné où elle m'a fait signe : « T'es trop high, parle plus ».
J'suis tout seul et j'me dis : « En fait, ça fait vraiment longtemps que j'ai pas ouvert la bouche pour faire des sons ».
Donc c'est le-- Mais c'est juste que j'aime bien le fait qu'on soit collectivement vraiment stupides. J'veux dire, on aime tous les histoires.
Tu parles dans un bar, tu vas commander une bière, t'entends le voisin dire : « Ah, ma collègue Nancy m'a dit ça l'autre jour ».
Et tout à coup, tu ne peux pas vivre sans savoir ce que sa collègue Nancy a dit, et tu dis-
J'ai bien peur que ce soit juste toi, Dan. Moi, je m'en fous un peu de sa collègue Nancy.
Ouais, mais t'as pas vu Nancy, fieu. Elle est, regarde, une meuf comme ça, mon ami. Enfin bref. On aime bien les his-- le fait qu'on considère le cinéma comme un art noble est une des choses les plus ridicules de l'histoire de l'univers.
J'veux dire, on aime les marionnettes pour adultes, quoi. Comment est-ce qu'on peut se prendre aus-
J'sais pas, j'ai pas compris la transition là pour le coup.
Mais on aime, j'veux dire, toi, tu dis que tu t'en fous de l'histoire de Nancy, mais j'suis sûr que t'aimes le cinéma ou les séries télé.
J'veux dire, t'aimes suivre les histoires de gens qui existent pas. À quel point t'es crétin, toi ? Qu'est-ce que ça peut te foutre ?
Bah en même temps, Nancy, euh-
Bah Nancy, elle existe. Crois-moi, elle existe à Calv house. Mais ce que j'veux dire, c'est que c'est beau. J'trouve ça beau, le fait qu'on aime les histoires quand on est petit pour s'endormir ou pour rêver.
Puis quand on est plus vieux, on aime encore les histoires. C'est juste qu'au lieu que ce soit des marionnettes ou nos parents qui nous inventent des conneries, on regarde Netflix, mais c'est les mêmes choses.
On regarde des gens qu'on a déjà vus dans 11 autres séries puis on fait : « Ouais, c'est vraiment un comptable ».
Et donc, sans transition, tu me disais avant le podcast que t'allais justement produire une fiction pour Ovios, c'est ça ?
Exactement. C'est vrai que c'était pas dans le podcast qu'on a dit ça. On l'a dit dans le podcast ou on l'a pas dit ?
Non, non, non. J'crois que c'était avant que je lance le podcast.
Je sais pas si j'ai le droit de le dire, mais j'ai un deal avec la-
RTBF
Pour faire, j'ai six épisodes, j'en ai tourné cinq sur six. C'est des petits épisodes courts de deux minutes, avec ma mère.
C'est un concept où en gros, ma mère vient me chercher à l'aéroport après mes voyages et on est deux minutes en bagnole.
Et la seule raison pour laquelle j'avais envie de faire ça, c'est que ma mère est une star qui n'est connue que par moi.
Mais elle, c'est du-
C'est bien dit
C'est d'une humiliance extrême de voir à quel point cette personne qui n'a jamais joué la comédie de sa vie me torche le cul comme actrice.
Mais vous la voyez, vous faites : « Quand même, voici quelqu'un qui a gagné un César et un imbécile ». C'est vraiment ça à quoi ça ressemble.
Et limite, ça me fait rire à quel point le décalage de talent entre les deux est extrême. Mais ma mère est absolument merveilleuse.
C'est une actrice de génie qui n'a aucune idée à quel point c'est une actrice de génie. Et ça va sortir, j'espère, avant la fin de l'année, mais j'suis en ce moment même en train de peaufiner des montages.
Là, j'ai envoyé à la production les trois premiers épisodes et j'attends des retours. J'imagine que j'peux pas en parler si c'est pas encore à ce stade-là.
J'imagine que j'peux pas en parler, donc faites comme si j'avais rien dit.
Mais ouais, donc tu me disais la fiction, c'est bien moins intéressant que l'histoire de Diane qui existe vraiment.
Mais en même temps, tu écris la fiction, donc j't'ai un peu cassé, Dan Gagnon.
Non, mais j'suis un imbécile. J'ai jamais prétendu le contraire. Moi, je profite du fait que les gens aiment autant les histoires que moi, c'est tout.
J'pense qu'à partir du moment où, j'veux dire, tout est,
tout n'est qu'une vaste pyramide de Maslow, Guillaume Hachez. Mais une fois que t'as mangé, que t'as un toit, puis que t'as des gens qui t'aiment, puis que tu sais dormir, puis faire un peu d'activités, tout ce que tu veux, c'est être diverti.
Donc j'essaie de faire des belles histoires, puis des fois elles sont tristes.
La pyramide de Maslow, c'est clairement le truc que t'entends dans ton premier cours de philo que tu reçois et puis tu passes le reste de tes jours à essayer de le placer dans une conversation sans y arriver.
Moi, c'est plutôt les sophismes que j'essaie de placer toute ma vie, mais la pyramide de Maslow, c'est en gros, si t'es pas heureux et tu manges mal, tu dors mal et que tu fais pas de sport
Non mais c'est bon, tu vas pas nous expliquer la pyramide de Maslow là, tu te calmes.
Oh que oui ! Puis j'vais t'expliquer le théorème de Pythagore après. Puis si t'es pas content, Guillaume H., j'vais te raconter une histoire de l'alphabet.
Est-ce que tu savais qu'à la base, l'alphabet n'avait que 22 lettres ? Et puis le projet était d'en faire 30, mais après, ils ont créé X, Y, Z,
W, X, Y, Z, pardon, et ils se sont rendu compte que c'était les quatre lettres les moins utilisées de la langue française.
Et donc, ils ont abandonné les quatre dernières lettres, mais qu'on peut retrouver sur Internet. Quelles étaient les quatre dernières lettres qui devaient constituer l'alphabet ?
Mais ça n'a aucun sens parce que l'alphabet n'a pas été inventé par la langue française.
Ah ah ! Or did it ?
Bien, sans transition. Le : « Ouais, mais tu vois aussi. »
J'suis tellement-- en fait, je ris parce que j'suis tellement désolé pour toi, parce que moi, je m'amuse et j'me dis : « Guillaume H., ça fait longtemps qu'il pense à ce podcast-là.
Il a interviewé des gens vachement intelligents qui ont un impact sur le monde. » Puis il se dit : « Je vais interviewer Dan Gagnon.
Peut-être que sous la surface puérile, y aura quelque chose de plus que du trivial. » Et là, il se dit : « Non, et j'ai perdu toute ma soirée alors que j'aurais pu genre worship Satan comme je fais les autres journées de la semaine.
» Si j'étais toi, Guillaume H., comme je travaille dans le monde du podcast, je cultiverais le mystère. C'est pour ça que peu de gens savent que, en réalité, je suis un murloc.
Murloc, c'est un truc de-- tu joues à Hearthstone ou pas ?
Mais occasionnellement, mais j'ai lâché ces dernières années. Mais en plus, c'est pas un truc de Hearthstone, c'est un truc de Warcraft.
Putain, Guillaume H., tu me déçois. Tu sais que Hearthstone, c'est fait avec ces-- Hearthstone, genre Heroes of Warcraft.
Mais bien sûr. Mais bien sûr. Mais donc je dis avant que ce soit un truc de Hearthstone, c'était déjà un truc de Warcraft.
J'ai regardé le film cette semaine. J'ai regardé le film Warcraft produit en 2016. Et tu sais quoi ?
C'est la pire mendice du monde, non ?
C'était absolument parfait et je ne te permets pas. Tu sais pourquoi c'était absolument parfait ? Parce que quand y avait des noms de personnages dans ma tête, j'faisais : « Haha, j'ai la carte.
» Et à un moment dans le film, y a un seul moment où y a une référence-
Y a un personnage que t'avais pas et donc t'as dépensé 5 € pour l'avoir, c'est ça ?
Oh, tu veux pas savoir combien j'ai dépensé sur Hearthstone. T'sais quoi ? J'vais jamais raconter ça parce que tout le monde s'en bat les couilles.
Et donc tu vas me le dire.
Moi, c'est ça, je dépense pas d'argent dans la vie. Dépenser de l'argent m'angoisse horriblement. Genre j'ai pas--
mes fringues, en ce moment même, les deux seuls pantalons que j'ai sont des pantalons qui sont troués, pas parce que j'suis cool, mais parce qu'ils sont vieux.
Sinon, j'ai que des pantalons plusieurs fois qui sont troués aussi. Mais genre, littéralement, vous pouvez voir à la télé, j'fais de la télé avec un pantalon, un jean gris, il est troué au niveau de la poche droite.
Checkez, il vient d'être troué maintenant. Je vais le porter pour la prochaine de Sans Chichi. Vous pouvez voir l'invité, c'est Éric Antoine.
Et je vais pas changer jusqu'à ce qu'il me fasse des commentaires. Je change pas parce que je m'en bats les couilles.
J'ai de l'angoisse à dépenser du pognon. Et y a un soir, j'étais sur Hearthstone et je voulais absolument un deck et j'avais pas les cartes qu'il fallait.
Et j'ai ouvert la boîte de Pandore, mon ami. J'ai dépensé de l'argent pour Hearthstone et j'ai pas su m'arrêter.
Le lendemain, j'avais une facture de 500 € sur iTunes. J'avais acheté pour 500 € de-- mais genre 500 €, la dernière fois que j'avais dépensé ça, c'était pour une bagnole, tu vois.
Je dépense pas cet argent-là. Et j'étais entre déçu de moi-même, angoissé d'avoir dépensé de l'argent et complètement excité d'avoir fait quelque chose de vraiment wild.
Mais depuis ce temps-là, je domine à Hearthstone parce que j'ai beaucoup de cartes. Et donc quand j'ai regardé Heroes of Warcraft, donc le film Warcraft, à un moment,
à un seul moment de tout le film, y a une référence au murloc, qui est un personnage, son genre de grenouille combattante.
Ouais, c'est ça, ouais.
Et la seule référence au murloc, c'est des personnages qui passent sur un pont.
Et le pont, donc par définition, est au-dessus d'une surface aqueuse, H2O pour les intimes, et t'as juste un cri du murloc qui est exactement le même cri que t'entends quand tu joues un murloc à Hearthstone, qui est : « Blblblblblblblblbl. »
C'est exactement ça, versé, Dan.
Et là, on a perdu tellement de monde. J'suis désolé, Guillaume H. Mais ça m'a donné,
ça m'a donné un petit feeling à l'intérieur de moi et ma femme qui encore une fois la meilleure, genre ma femme regarde mère Teresa lui crache à la gueule puis mère Teresa s'excuse et elle a raison de le faire.
Tu vois, c'est une personne merveilleuse. Et elle m'a regardé puis elle dit : « Tu passes un bon moment parce que tu reconnais des cartes.
» Et c'était pas dit genre de manière moqueuse ou méchante comme ça aurait pu l'être de façon tout à fait justifiée. C'était vraiment dit avec amour.
Et je l'ai regardée, j'ai fait : « Oui », avec le sourire niais de quelqu'un qui éjacule pour la première fois. Et c-
Tu me donneras le numéro de téléphone de ta femme.
C'est quelqu'un de merveilleusement enveloppant d'amour.
Ouais, je ne sais pas s'il y a une meilleure preuve d'amour que ça. Mais donc ouais, ça fait bientôt deux heures qu'on enregistre ça.
Donc ouais, j'vais juste-
Tu vas aller dormir, toi, Guillaume.
Il est minuit, on a déjà le 31 octobre. Mais non, moi, je passerais bien quatre heures, mais je me dis qu'en fait, on va perdre tous les auditeurs si on les a pas déjà perdus.
Ce que tu dis, c'est toi, ça t'intéresse, mais tu sais pas si ça va intéresser les autres.
Ah oui, effectivement, c'est un peu ça.
From before.
J'vais mettre un flashback ici, j'vais mettre une petite musique à la harpe et je vais replacer l'extrait tout à l'heure.
Est-ce que par-dessus la musique à la harpe, tu vas mettre : « Blblblblblblblbl. »
C'est mon nouveau jingle. Parce qu'au début de l'émission, je mets un petit bip pour passer de l'intro que je fais façon Marc Maron, parce qu'il n'intéresse personne.
Et je mets un petit bip pour passer de ça à l'émission principale. Mais pour celle-ci, je mettrai juste : « Blblblblblblblbl. » C'est parfait.
Tu me promets que tu vas le retrouver ?
Bah oui.
Tu me promets que tu vas le faire ?
Je te promets.
OK. Ce qui est génial avec ça, c'est que tout le monde le sait. Parce que pour les gens, ça fait genre deux heures qu'ils ont entendu ça, puis ils savaient pas d'où ça vient.
Et on est le M. Night Shyamalan des podcasts, la fin et la punchline de début.
On l'a fait, Dan, on y est arrivé. Mais donc, la conclusion-
Est-ce que je reviens la semaine prochaine ou ?
La conclusion que j'essaie de faire depuis une demi-heure, c'est de dire que-
Tu devrais parler à Anthony Mirelli, il connaît ta douleur.
Je te crois tout à fait. Ce que j'essaie de dire, c'est que Dan, on a placé tous tes podcasts, on a annoncé ton projet de production avec la RTBF, qui était censé être top secret, mais on s'en fout.
On a parlé de-- on a retracé toute ta carrière et on va surtout pas oublier de dire que tu es au Kings of Comedy Club à Ixelles le 21 et 28 novembre pour faire du rodage.
Tu reviens en Belgique, tu fais un petit tour et tu fais des blagues. Et d'ailleurs, y aura Fanny Ruwet,
la maman du réseau de podcast « J'aime bien quand tu parles », qui fera la première partie de ton show, puisqu'elle commence aussi à faire du stand-up.
Et moi, j'y serai aussi le 28, le 28, je dis. Mais du coup, c'est quoi ? C'est pour préparer ton spectacle de 2020, c'est ça ?
Je vais être honnête avec toi, je le sais pas encore ce que je vais faire. Tout ce que je peux promettre, c'est que ça va être du nouveau matériel.
Quoi qu'il arrive, c'est du nouveau matériel. Je vais pas—
Pas d'arnaque.
Et si c'est vraiment mauvais, je vais faire un entracte, puis je vais faire du vieux matériel parce que moi, je suis prê— Y a un contrat dans un comedy club, tu viens, puis tu sais pas ce que tu vas voir, puis des gens testent, mais moi,
ma fierté personnelle, c'est de dire : « T'es venu me voir, je veux que t'aies rigolé. »
Ouais, je comprends.
Donc si je t'ai pas fait rigoler avec des nouvelles blagues, je vais te faire rigoler avec des anciennes, mais je veux que tu viennes, t'aies vu quelque chose de spécial, puis t'aies rigolé.
Ouais, mais du coup, on espère qu'il va arriver des choses tout à fait horribles à ton épouse Flavie le 20 et 27 novembre.
Le 20 et 27 novembre.
De quoi ?
Oui, dis-moi.
Slow clap.
Mais je suis à moitié sincère en plus.
Guillaume Hachez, c'était parfait. Je ne parlerai plus de tout cet épisode. Je te remercie de m'avoir accueilli, de m'avoir laissé être qui je suis.
J'espère que j'ai pas ruiné tout ton podcast. J'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à le faire. Et si vous avez des questions, vous avez envie de discuter avec moi, sachez que je ne réponds jamais, mais je lis toutes les questions que vous me posez.
Donc merci beaucoup, bisous et à la prochaine, Guillaume Hachez. Longue vie à ton podcast. Je suis fantastiquement heureux de voir que des gens font des choses qui leur plaisent et je sais que ça, c'est quelque chose qui te plaisait profondément.
Et donc tu n'interviewes que des gens qui t'intéressent, sauf exception pour ici, mais que des gens qui t'intéressent.
Donc suivez son podcast, s'il vous plaît.
OK, mais donc tu fais la conclusion à ma place, tout va bien. OK, bah je vais, what he said.
Parfait. Merci beaucoup Guillaume et au plaisir la prochaine fois.
Salut Dan, à la prochaine. Et voilà, c'est déjà tout. Comme je l'ai dit dans l'intro, c'était un épisode un peu inhabituel, donc n'hésitez pas à me dire si ça vous a plu ou si au contraire, vous avez détesté.
Normalement, les prochains épisodes seront consacrés à des sujets plutôt sérieux.
Pour ne pas rater les prochains épisodes, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast sur iTunes, Spotify, YouTube, Pocket Cast ou votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
Il y a aussi les liens vers toutes les pages, vers les réseaux sociaux, dans la description. Voilà, merci d'avoir écouté et à dans deux semaines. Bye bye.
Oh, ça y est, ça enregistre, j'ai vu.
Ouais, je voulais faire une super intro super propre, mais voilà.
Excuse-moi, je suis désolé. C'est juste que je suis tellement nul techniquement que moi, à chaque fois que quelque chose fonctionne, je suis comme un gamin qui entendrait son chien parler.
Je fais comme : « Ah, je le savais ».
Et bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour un nouvel épisode de—
Oh, mais ça fait tellement longtemps que je suis moi que maintenant, j'ai de la peine pour les autres qui me fréquentent.
Parce que je me dis genre : « Oh » et je gâche tout. Je suis le Grinch du podcast